On an ordinary day in 1991, a young man known
by the initials J.S. went on a hike with four
of his friends on the wooded outskirts of
their small town.
Everything seemed perfectly normal until J.S.
began to feel a strange sense of familiarity,
like he had been in this spot before.
He couldn’t shake this weird feeling, but
thought nothing more of it.
Little did he know that this was a sign of
deadly things to come.
Several hours after first experiencing that
sense of deja vu, J.S. was found by the side
of the road, covered in cuts and scratches,
with his friends nowhere to be found.
This is the story of SCP - 939, an unforgettable
monster that you’ll never remember.
There was no way for J.S. to know that the
unsettling feeling he felt and the horrors
that followed it were the result of an experiment
conducted by the SCP Foundation, an experiment
with deadly unforeseen consequences.
J.S. and his friends were exposed to a substance
known only as AMN-C227 as part of a series
of tests performed by the SCP Foundation intended
to determine the effectiveness of this substance
as a deliberate amnestic.
Dealing with as many mysterious, secret creatures
and objects as they do, the SCP Foundation
has long needed a way to tamper with the memories
of those exposed to the foundation’s various
prisoners and test subjects, and, when the
foundation discovered AMN-C227, it seemed
like it might be perfect for this purpose.
So where did AMN-C227 come from?
Over a year before the incident with J.S.
and his friends, the SCP Foundation captured
SCP-939.
SCP-939 is a species of endothermic predators
that live and hunt in packs.
They are designated Keter class, and regarded
as highly dangerous and hostile to human life.
Native to caves, they have no eyes, translucent
red skin, and stand at an average of 2.2 meters
tall, with an average weight of 250 kg.
They have four limbs, each
ending in three-fingered
claws and a fourth opposable digit resembling
a thumb.
In addition to their sharp claws, their mouths
are filled with red, fang-like teeth that
reach up to 6 cm in length.
In place of their absent eyes,
they have light-sensitive
spots running along their backs, which are
covered in spines believed to detect changes
in air pressure and flow.
In addition to their many other terrifying
attributes, the internal anatomy of SCP-939
poses a biological mystery.
These creatures have no circulatory system
and no digestive tract.
That’s right, in spite of being predators
seemingly acting on a need to feed, they have
no stomach.
Instead, when they eat their food builds up
in their respiratory system until its presence
inhibits function, and then it is regurgitated.
In spite of being a creature that should not,
under any logical conditions, be able to live,
SCP-939 continues to persist, and is even
capable of giving birth to live young after
a gestation period of 12 months.
The SCP Foundation was able to study a litter
of these young that were born in captivity
in September of 1992, though the creatures
remain just as much of a scientific mystery
as they were upon first discovery.
Everything about them seems to defy the logic
of the natural world - which, to be fair,
is really nothing new for the Foundation.
The respiratory system of SCP-939 was found
to exhale small traces of an airborne amnestic
substance, given the name AMN-C227.
This compound blocks the formation of memories
for the duration of exposure to it, plus a
thirty minute period following the exposure,
give or take a few minutes.
It is colorless, odorless, tasteless, and
completely undetectable in the bloodstream
after only 60 minutes.
AMN-C227 was approved for use as a Class C
Amnestic by the SCP Foundation in 1990 following
some initial tests.
However, after one particular incident involving
a young man and his friends, the official
use of AMN-C227 was suspended.
J.S. and three of his four friends were previously
given a dose of AMN-C227, though the details
of why they were given the amnestic have since
been stricken from the record.
Several months after being exposed to AMN-C227,
J.S. and friends went out on their ill-fated
hiking trip.
While hiking, J.S. was suddenly overcome with
a sense of deja vu.
When he mentioned it to his friends, three
of them agreed that they felt it too.
One of the group, another young man - who
had not been exposed to
AMN-C227 - was uncomfortable
and decided to go home.
J.S. and the remaining three members of the
group made the choice to stay in the woods
and try to determine what was triggering the
unusual feeling of familiarity.
As they got closer and closer to a large cave
near the hiking trail, the sense of having
been there before grew stronger and stronger.
Armed with only one flashlight and a foolish
curiosity, the four went inside the cave.
They made their way deeper and deeper into
the darkness, not knowing why they felt this
way or what they might find inside.
None of the group could explain just what
felt so familiar, only that the further they
made their way into the cave, the more pronounced
the feeling became.
It was getting late, and they knew they should
have been afraid to venture so deep into a
cave with only one light source and no knowledge
of what lay inside, but still they pressed
on.
One of the group remarked that they should
turn back, but the others refused to listen.
They wanted to know what they were getting
close to, what was drawing them deeper and
deeper into the cave.
Unfortunately for them, they would get their
answer.
In the heart of the cave was a pack of SCP-939,
waiting patiently for their prey to wander
into their domain.
There are no witnesses to account for what
exactly happened to J.S. and his companions,
but we can reasonably piece the events together
from what happened after.
Once the friends reached the heart of the
cave, the creatures were on them in seconds,
raking them with their sharp claws and biting
with their fangs.
SCP-939 are larger and stronger than most
people, so it was probably not much of a fight.
However, while his friends were being devoured,
J.S. was somehow able to scramble out of the
cave and make his way into the woods in search
of help.
Under the influence of the AMN-C227 that had
built up in the cave from the presence of
the pack of SCP-939, J.S. lost a large portion
of his memory of the event.
He found himself on the side of the highway
late at night, seriously injured and his clothes
ripped.
An officer found him there, and asked him
to stay still and remain calm until an ambulance
could arrive.
J.S. was still in a panic and attempted to
run away from the officer, begging to be released
so that he could get away.
He babbled incoherently about the color red,
screaming over and over again about the “red,”
though when prompted he could not explain
what the “red” he was screaming about
referred to.
His friends were not with him.
Just as the officer managed to calm J.S.,
the ambulance arrived.
Its flashing red lights sent him into another
frenzy, and he attempted to escape custody,
claiming that the red lights were “going
to get” him.
The official police report described J.S.
as perhaps being under the influence of a
powerful hallucinogen.
That he was just having a “bad trip,”
but the SCP foundation knew better.
The foundation conducted an interview with
J.S. about his experience, and determined
that SCP-939 was certainly involved.
As part of their cover-up effort, they strongly
implicated J.S. in the disappearance and death
of his friends.
He was convicted of manslaughter, though the
bodies of his friends were never found.
It is rumored that the SCP Foundation hired
him on a prison work release program, and
that he now works as a member of the janitorial
staff at one of the Foundation’s facilities.
This incident led to the suspension of the
use of AMN-C227, as it revealed some vital
and disturbing information about the compound’s
side effects.
After exposure to AMN-C227, a person who found
themselves exposed to it again would experience
a sense of familiarity, and feel compelled
to investigate the source of this feeling.
Essentially, anyone treated with AMN-C227
and not made aware of the existence - and
danger - of SCP-939 would become a perfect
victim, primed to be attracted to dens of
SCP-939.
It is likely that this side effect is not
a coincidence, but rather a deliberate hunting
tactic designed to attract prey that had somehow
managed to escape.
With no memory of their attack at the hands
of SCP-939, this previous intended prey would
find themselves drawn to the same den or even
a new one, not knowing that they were walking
back into near certain death.
While the SCP foundation suspended the use
of AMN-C227 as a Class C amnestic, they did
recruit a team of SCP field operatives to
take advantage of this side effect.
This team of operatives was
deliberately administered
a dose of AMN-C227 and briefed on its effects,
as well as the dangers of following the feeling
of deja vu should it surface in the field.
These infected officers were essentially used
as bloodhounds, relying on any sense of unusual
familiarity to sniff out new dens of SCP-939
so that they could be captured and contained
by the foundation.
As far as we know, this operation is still
ongoing today.
However, now that the foundation has a sufficient
number of specimens to study, additional dens
of SCP-939 that are discovered are ordered
to be immediately destroyed.
As for the SCP-939 still in captivity?
They are contained in environmentally regulated
and negatively pressurized cells with walls
of reinforced concrete.
The doors to the cells are air-tight to prevent
the leakage of any AMN-C227, and any personnel
that interact with one of the creatures is
required to wear Level C Hazmat gear to avoid
exposure, and follow decontamination procedures
upon exiting the cell.
All SCP-939 have subdermal tracking devices
implanted to find them in the event of escape.
Only one SCP-939 has given birth in the time
that the creatures have been in captivity,
and only one of the litter survived.
Strangely, SCP-939 young look indistinguishable
from human infants, and change their physical
appearance at some yet unknown point as they
age.
If any more offspring are produced, they will
immediately be separated from the parent and
studied.
The SCP foundation has redacted all information
about the location of these creatures or the
incident involving J.S., refusing to reveal
where their natural habitat is.
All that we know is that they are found in
caves in the woods outside of a small town.
It could be any town, even yours.
Sp if you’re ever out hiking, and are struck
with a sudden feeling of deja vu?
Don’t investigate, don’t get curious,
just go home.
It might just save your life.
The fabric of our world is littered with doorways
if you know where to look for them. Tears,
portals, anomalies, all leading to places and
planes beyond human imagining and understanding,
and SCP-2317, otherwise known as A Door to
Another World, certainly fits that description.
Contained and kept at all times under the watch
of armed guards, SCP-2317 appears to be a simple
and unsuspecting wooden door in its frame.
It hardly looks like it requires such extreme
round-the-clock security or needs a strange,
secretive ritual that the Foundation performs,
presumably to keep the door closed. But, of
course, sometimes the most interesting thing
about a closed doorway isn’t where
it leads, it’s what it keeps out.
Even by the Foundation’s already-high standards,
the requirements and regulations for personnel
who are assigned to SCP-2317 seem oddly specific.
Psychological testing is standard practice for to
work for the Foundation, but an additional
hurdle that anyone has to clear before even
getting to glimpse at this unassuming wooden
door is having a score of at least seventy-two
on the Milgram Obedience Examination. It is also
mandatory that personnel assigned to maintaining
it are both unmarried, with no children
or next-of-kin, as well as an unwavering,
unquestioning loyalty to the Foundation,
pure devotion to its code and objectives.
These may seem like strange requirements,
after all, SCP-2317 is just a door…isn’t it?
Perhaps there’s a reason that the Foundation
keeps so much of the information about SCP-2317
buried deep under layers upon layers of security,
with only the Overseer Council privy to the full
details of its strange nature. Knowledge, as they
say, is power - but maybe knowing too much about
whatever is behind that door can prove deadly.
Still, if SCP-2317 is a Door to Another World,
an alternate dimension or parallel reality,
it must be safe enough to visit. After all,
the Foundation has been sending personnel
in there on a regular basis. Daily, in fact.
According to the O5 Council, this
is done as part of a procedure to
maintain Active Containment of…something
lurking beyond that old wooden doorframe.
But what could possibly warrant such
constant maintenance and surveillance?
In accordance with the Foundation’s guidelines,
all staff are required to rotate out of observing
SCP-2317 after every two months and spend the
following third month in full psychological
counselling before they are permitted to return to
the containment unit housing the Door to Another
World. It was after one of these month-long
periods of evaluation that a Foundation guard
was informed that his security clearance
had been raised to Level 3 and that he’d
been selected for the duty of carrying out
220-Calabasas. He knew the name instantly;
this was the title given to the daily containment
procedure that absolutely had to be carried out.
The guard didn’t question these orders, after
all, he’d been selected precisely because of
his loyalty to the Foundation. He did make one
request to his commanding officer, however:
he wanted to know what had happened to the
last guard that had performed the procedure.
“Didn’t make it out of psychological
evaluation,” the officer replied.
Not letting this affect his dedication, the guard
was told to prepare for Procedure 220-Calabasas.
Along with a fellow member of Foundation security
personnel, the guard was instructed to gather
everything on a strange list. The first was
a pre-selected member of Class-D Personnel,
specifically a convicted murderer. Class-D
refers to ‘Disposable Class’ personnel,
expendable individuals recruited by the
Foundation for the sole purpose of testing SCPs.
Class-Ds were usually prison inmates
repurposed for SCP testing, and the
one chosen for 220-Calabasas was no exception,
serving multiple life sentences for murders,
or at least that was what the guard
had been told. A Foundation personnel
member instructed him to refer to the Class-D
solely as the ‘assistant’ from that point on.
Next, the guard collected a live
chicken, an obsidian-edged knife,
a silver aspergillum and aspersorium, to be
filled with 500ccs of Holy Water that had
been blessed by a priest of the Abrahamic faith,
and finally a one-kiloton nuclear device, which,
according to instructions, was to only
be detonated in the unlikely event of a
catastrophic containment failure.
In other words, the last resort.
After following his instructions to the letter and
without question, the guard and his colleague were
briefed. The Foundation personnel member informed
them that he’d be joining and leading them in the
procedure. The staff member also specified that
henceforth he be referred to as the ‘celebrant’
until the completion of 220-Calabasas. The
guard was acutely aware of how specific these
instructions were, but trusted in the Foundation,
knowing that if they wanted this procedure
performed a certain way, then it was in everyones’
best interest to carry out the orders to the
letter. But what the celebrant then went on to
explain, raised far more questions about SCP-2317
and the nature of Procedure 220-Calabasas. The
Class-D joining them, wasn’t actually a Class-D.
The assistant, as they were now referred to,
was in reality another Foundation staff member,
with a Level 4 security clearance,
specifically tailored to SCP-2317.
Every member of staff entering through SCP-2317
and taking an active role in 220-Calabasas needed
to be informed that this assistant was not to be
harmed or treated as a member of Disposable Class.
Fighting back the nagging question of why
the Foundation would employ this subterfuge,
the guard, along with his fellow security
officer, the celebrant and assistant,
prepared for their departure through
the Door to Another World at solar noon,
when the sun was highest over SCP-2317.
Solar noon, chickens and holy water,
this all seemed like an oddly-occult
combination for the Foundation.
As they entered the old wooden door, beyond
lay a barren salt plane, stretching out for
kilometers in every direction. This alternate
dimension, according to the briefing,
was designated SCP-2317-Prime. The guard
immediately noticed a ring of seven pillars
directly ahead of the group as they entered, each
of them bearing intricately-detailed engravings
unlike anything from any era of ancient history.
Procedure 220-Calabasas was carried out quickly,
but carefully, the guard watching as the celebrant
and assistant were careful not to miss a step.
First, the celebrant scattered Holy Water
into the center of the pillars with the
aspergillum and aspersorium, looking down
at his feet and keeping a steady pace as he
stepped counter-clockwise around them. The guard
watched intently as the celebrant completed his
circuit around the pillars and turned to the
assistant, anointing his head with Holy Water.
“Seven Seals, Seven Rings, Seven Thrones
for the Scarlet King,” he said aloud.
The assistant, with the obsidian blade in
his hand, took the chicken and dispatched it
in sacrifice, letting its blood mix with the
Holy Water. He then repeated the celebrant’s
circuit in the opposite direction, before
stepping into the center of the stone pillars.
“Blood for the Old Gods, Water for the New King,”
the assistant recited, pouring the remaining mix
of blood and Holy Water over a patch of
salt in the middle of the seven pillars.
Even though he knew it wasn’t his
place to question the Foundation,
as the 220-Calabasas procedure took place, the
guard couldn’t help but wonder what all this was
for. It seemed so…ritualistic, like something
deeply religious or even magical. He’d never
bought into all that occult mumbo-jumbo,
even while working for the Foundation,
but he had learned not to question anything, even
the strangest and most inexplicable of sights.
Little did he know that beneath his feet, was an
ancient and unknowable horror. A beast, chained
and lying in wait. Contained in a chamber directly
underneath the pillars, sat an impossibly-large
creature. Humanoid and obese, its body covered
entirely in scales thicker than armour plating.
Branch-like horns protruded from its jawless
head, pointing up to chains that hung from the
seven pillars above, each one hooked into the
entity’s back. All but one of the chains was
broken, a final, withering shackle keeping the
Devourer of Worlds in its underground prison.
Ever since 1894 BCE, when Erikeshan mystics
imprisoned it, the Devourer has been waiting
patiently for its inevitable freedom. It knows,
as well as the Foundation, that nothing can be
done to prevent the final chain from one day
breaking. Even Procedure 220-Calabasas won’t
keep the creature contained, it’s nothing more
than a smokescreen, an act, designed to create
an illusion of active containment and maintain
Foundation morale until a permanent solution
can be devised to keep SCP-2317 imprisoned.
Of course, if the guard had known this, it would
have also explained the need for a one-kiloton
nuclear device as part of this staged ritual.
Procedure 220-Calabasas has all the components
to trick everyone below the O5 Council,
emulating religious and occult rituals, the
increased level of security surrounding the
procedure and its purpose, and telling staff
that any failure to correctly, and completely,
perform the 220-Calabasas procedure will result
in an XK-Class End of the World Scenario.
All these elements work together to conceal
the truth: that one day, the Devourer will
escape and lay waste to our dimension.
Knowledge is power, and maybe knowing
too much truly is deadly. Perhaps if the guard
had learned any of this, he’d have understood
why his predecessor never made it out of
psychological evaluation. Maybe if he had
questioned the purpose of Procedure 220-Calabasas,
he'd have learned the true nature of SCP-2317,
and what that doorway kept out. But he was
loyal to the Foundation, through and through.
As the team finished performing 220-Calabasas
and returned though the wooden door, the guard
took one last glance over his shoulder at the vast
salt plane. The entire dimension was calm, silent,
but not peaceful: it was patient. The
entity had waited centuries for its time,
and now all it would take was the breaking
of the seventh and final chain. One day.
The door was closed behind the guard as he,
the celebrant, the assistant and his fellow
security officer stepped back through,
their work done and, as far as they knew,
preventing catastrophe for another day.
Only the Foundation higher-ups,
the Overseer Council, are aware of the true
danger posed by SCP-2317 and its sole inhabitant.
Current predictions are that at some point within
the next thirty years, the Devourer of Worlds
will be freed. Any and all attempts to repair or
recreate the chains holding it in place have so
far failed. As such, the O5 Council has elected to
continue providing Foundation personnel with the
ignorant hope that Procedure 220-Calabasas
is an effective strategy for containment.
As we’ve said, sometimes the most interesting
thing about a closed door isn’t where it leads,
it’s what it keeps out. In the case of SCP-2317,
the unassuming wooden door holds at bay an ancient
creature of untold power, that will one day break
free and wreak havoc in our dimension. Nothing the
Foundation does can prevent it, or keep it
contained behind the Door to Another World,
and only the Overseer Council knows that
any and all efforts to do so are futile.
With all that in mind, we can only hope
that the doorway of SCP-2317 stays closed,
at least for a little while longer.
SCP-173 - It’s one of the most iconic anomalies
ever contained by the SCP Foundation.
This neck-snapping Site-19 celebrity is known
and feared by everyone who works at the Foundation
since being contained in 1993, its nubby,
concrete hands metaphorically,
and quite literally,
stained with the blood of countless people.
But this mostly immobile oddity wasn’t always
a resident of Site-19, and the story of how
exactly it ended up there - and more importantly,
why - is far more ridiculous, insane, and
downright terrifying than you could ever imagine.
So buckle up, SCP Fans.
This is the dramatic tale of how this homicidal
piece of modern art ended
up at the SCP Foundation’s
largest containment site.
To give you an idea of just how weird this
origin story is, we’re gonna have to leap
forward to the year 2045.
We know what you’re thinking: Isn’t this
a prequel?
How can it take place in the future?
Sit tight, folks, it’ll all make sense in
the end.
Site-91 is where we lay our scene, under the
watchful eyes of Site Director Dr. James Long,
a senior researcher with Level 4 Security
Clearance - the second highest at the Foundation.
Dr. Long had given decades of devotion and
his expertise to the Foundation; he was a
proud man, who wore his life of service to
the containment cause as a badge of honor.
After years of dodging death while researching
some of the most dangerous anomalies that
Site-91 had to offer, he had ascended to the
rank of Site Director which represented the
culmination of his life’s work.
And in his new position of power, he’d only
proved himself further - running a tight ship,
and reducing the number of containment breaches
across the board.
Nobody could say that Dr. Long wasn’t extremely
talented at his job, which is why he was so
confused when he received an email from Alexandra
Nala, an Administrative Assistant working
directly for the O5 Council.
It was the type of email that no Site Director
ever wanted to receive: Dr. Long was being
told that, with no input or oversight from
him, the majority of Site-91’s anomalies
were going to be taken to an undisclosed location
for “Safer Containment.”
The list contained nearly every meaningful
detainee contained on the site, including
of course, SCP-173.
This particular anomaly had been contained
at the site for 37 years after being delivered
there in 2008.
Dr. Long had devised a perfect method to minimize
containment breaches in that time - creating
a sprinkler system within the chamber that
washes away the waste products produced by
173, reducing the need for risky human contact.
But that didn’t matter.
Despite Dr. Long’s loyalty and efficacy
in serving the SCP Foundation, the decision
had already been made, with no chance of reversing
it.
According to Nala, the motion to remove most
of Site-91’s anomalies had received unanimous
approval from the O5 Council, and the operations
for the transfer would be commandeered by
the Department of Extra-Universal Affairs,
headed by Senior Agent Sven Kisch.
Dr. Long was both upset and confused.
He was producing some of the best results
across the entire Foundation, so why were
they taking away all of his anomalies?
Did someone on the O5 Council have it out
for him?
Dr. Long replied to Nala, asking if - considering
how severe the relocation operation was going
to be - whether he could get more information
on where the anomalies were being moved to,
and why.
He felt that, at the very least, he was owed
some answers on this.
Nala and her superiors didn’t feel quite
the same way.
She replied that Dr. Long sadly didn’t have
the clearance to know any of the operation’s
particulars - this information was reserved
for those with Level 5 Clearance, and members
of the Multi-Universal Department.
All that Dr. Long needed to do was stay out
of the way, and everything would be taken
care of for him.
But that wasn’t enough for Dr. Long.
He needed to know more.
He needed to understand why this seemingly
random decision had been made.
Realizing that Nala and the O5 Council were
a dead end as far as information was concerned,
he instead reached out to the next best thing:
Senior Agent Sven Kisch, the member of the
Department of Extra-Universal Affairs who
was spearheading the relocation mission.
Dr. Long implored the Agent to give him extra
information on where all the Site-91 anomalies
were being moved, and why they were being
moved in the first place.
Predictably, he was once again stonewalled,
being told that any information regarding
the project was above his level of clearance.
In a move that seemed decidedly spiteful,
Agent Kisch signed off by saying that he looked
forward to seeing Dr. Long at Site-91.
And not long after that, he did.
Agent Kisch along with a huge number of agents
and task force members from the Multi-U Department
arrived on site, bearing state of the art
containment equipment.
An exasperated Dr. Long wasn’t able to glean
any more information from this experience
- the Multi-U agents were ruthlessly efficient,
transferring the lion’s share of the anomalies
into temporary containment and transporting
them off-site within a few hours.
By the time they were done, Dr. Long and his
staff were left with one of the most desolate
and empty containment sites on the Foundation’s
books.
Here was Dr. Long, with decades of service,
and climbing the organizational ladder, only
to be left as a glorified babysitter for a
handful of low-priority anomalous items.
It all felt like a cruel joke.
After several days of nothing happening in
the now-incredibly-uneventful Site-91, a bored
Dr. Long reached out to a
friend of his - Researcher
Nurul Shafiqah binte Ahmad Ibrahim, whom he
called by the nickname Shaq - to vent his
frustrations.
She commiserated, sharing her sympathy for
his suddenly much less
exciting working conditions,
but saying that at least the job should be
a little less lethal now.
Shaq didn’t know it yet, but on this particular
point, she was terribly wrong.
Dr. Long shared his theory that perhaps some
sites were being consolidated so the Foundation
could save money, and that this would lead
to layoffs.
Shaq essentially told him that he was worrying
too much.
The reality was that Dr. Long had some very
good reasons to be worried, his problem was
that he hadn’t been worrying about the right
things.
In Foundation Containment Area-179, something
awful was brewing.
As usual, guards posted around SCP-2317 - an
old door containing a portal to another world
- waited while Foundation staff and D-Classes
performed the standard Procedure 220-Calabasas
ritual within.
They were dealing with one of the most dangerous
anomalies in the entire universe, but even
then, after decades of service, one can become
numb to such things.
Suddenly, without warning, the door opened
and a terrified Foundation researcher tumbled
out, panting heavily, eyes bulging in existential
horror.
He screamed the words that he had long hoped
would never be spoken in
his or even his children’s
lifetime, “It happened!
The chains have broken!
The Devourer is free!”
The siren sounded, and an alert spread out
across the entire Foundation database: SCP-2317
is compromised, SCP-2317-K - the Devourer
of Worlds - is free.
If the creature escapes Area-179, an XK-Class
End of the World Scenario is basically assured,
so all efforts will be taken to make sure
that the creature does not escape at any cost.
And they really did mean any cost.
The old wooden door of SCP-2317 splintered,
as an immense, scaly hand sprang forth, and
clawed a wave of devastation through the
containment
chamber.
Guards were dispatched in the hundreds with
heavy weaponry to buy some time, firing as
the Devourer, a beast the size of a mountain
rose from the ground, staring at the terrified
humans below with its one gigantic red eye.
It couldn’t even feel the bullets, explosives,
or incendiary and laser weaponry being used
on it.
The monster just shrugged it off, and murdered
nearly all its attackers with one swipe of
its claw.
In a final desperate act, hoping to kill or
at least slow down the beast, staff at Area-179
made the ultimate sacrifice, and detonated
the entire on-site nuclear arsenal.
The explosion disintegrated the entire facility
in an instant, and unleashed a radioactive
shockwave that carried destruction for miles.
But it wasn’t enough.
SCP-2317-K walked out of the mushroom cloud
without a scratch on it, ready to show the
human world what real destruction meant.
At this point, the battle was already effectively
lost, but the Foundation refused to go down
without a fight.
They dispatched all available mobile task
forces - including Mobile Task Force Nu-7,
Hammer Down, a heavily-armed, battalion-strength
task force created to combat the biggest and
most extensive threats imaginable.
And it wasn’t even just the Foundation - true
existential threats have a way of uniting
people, as the GOC and even the Chaos Insurgency
temporarily put aside their differences to
take the fight to the Devourer.
But would any of it be enough?
Barrages of cruise missiles and ICBMs did
nothing to halt the Devourer’s assault,
as it rampaged, destroying towns and cities
at first, then regions, then whole nations.
Swarms of scrambled jets and helicopters were
knocked out of the sky with casual swipes.
The creature bulldozed over landscapes teeming
with tanks and heavy artillery vehicles.
It snapped aircraft carriers in half as it
waded from ocean to ocean, systematically
destroying everything in its path.
Even satellite-mounted orbital cannons and
the heavy energy weapons of MTF Tau-5, also
known as "Samsara", did nothing to faze the
Devourer.
It was finally coming to fruition: The dreaded
XK Class End of the World Scenario, and none
of the Foundation’s expertise, advanced
technology, or limitless resources could do
anything to stop it.
They aided in evacuation efforts, getting
as many people as they could out of harm’s
way as the Devourer rampaged and destroyed,
but even that was doing little more than borrowing
time.
Eventually, the Devourer would destroy all
of them.
There would be nothing left.
And all Dr. James Long could do was watch
helplessly from an almost empty Site-91, waiting
for the tide of destruction to reach him.
Of course, other Foundation employees - most
prominently, Senior Agent Sven Kisch and the
Multi-U Department - had other concerns.
All they needed to do was archive data for
extraction.
Extraction to where, you ask, seeing as the
world seems to be at its end here?
Well, Universe 7392-Epsilon-Blue-Lima, otherwise
known as our universe, circa 1993.
The Foundation works across the multiverse,
and an XK-Class End of the World Scenario
in one universe really isn’t necessarily
a problem in others.
On the orders of the O5 Council, Agent Kisch
and his men are charged with extracting data
and valuable anomalies like SCP-173 from doomed
universes.
O5 knew that Dr. Long’s universe - Universe
5643-Gamma-Orange-Delta -
was due for an apocalyptic
visit from the Devourer of Worlds any day
now.
That’s why the Multi-U team went in to extract
everything worth saving.
Dr. Long and the millions of other Level-4
and below employees of that universe’s Foundation
were never told of their impending doom.
After all, that sort of thing could probably
lead to unnecessary stress.
And what they don’t know won’t hurt them
- until, of course, it does.
In 1993, these anomalous, doomed universe
SCPs were divided among our universe’s various
applicable containment sites.
SCP-173, as you already know, ended up in
Site-19.
But sadly for the people working there, all
the actual data on this entity’s file was
lost in translation, so as far as they knew,
173 was little more than a big, weird statue
with apparently dangerous properties.
Upon first placing it in its containment chamber
in the Site-19 Euclid Wing, Foundation legend
Dr. Bright, unaware of just what he had here,
assigned Dr. William Motto to begin research
on the entity.
He recommended that the Researcher bring two
D-Classes for testing.
When Dr. Motto was faced with the anomalous
entity’s blank file, he gave a sigh, and
began to write something in its description
box: “Moved to Site-19 1993.
Origin is as of yet unknown…”
Wasn’t that a delightful little tale?
Now we know how SCP-173 made its way into
Site-19, and what our own universe may have
to look forward to in 2045.
So remember, if you ever see Agent Sven Kisch
planning a transfer of anomalies out of your
site, maybe consider using some of that PTO,
and maybe consider putting a downpayment on
a nice, cozy apocalypse bunker over in Iceland…
Jay and Michael were a pair of urban exploration
YouTubers looking for their big break. You
might remember their video exploring the
dead mall on the outskirts of your town,
or the supposedly “haunted” 1950s
insane asylum out in the styx,
but you certainly won’t find these videos
anywhere online. After The Incident at SCP - 823,
all of their content was scrubbed away from even
the most comprehensive internet archives. “Why?”
you ask. Because these unfortunate urban explorers
decided that their big break would be exploring
a certain abandoned theme park. And it would
be one of the last decisions they ever made.
Michael and Jay had heard rumors about the
theme park. Its name was lost to time, as
was the date of its opening and closing, and the
reason it was even abandoned in the first place.
Even some of the most hardcore urban explorers
didn’t dare to tread there. Something about it,
a good friend had once told Jay, just didn’t feel
right. Sometimes, if you dare to venture into the
forest near the theme park at night, you can
still hear music. The jolly, piping tunes of
rides and carnival stands still beckoning. As
if to say, “We’re still here. Come and play.”
Of course, none of this
frightened Jay and Michael.
They could already smell the sponsorships
from headlamp and compact camera companies.
No amount of anxiety would stop them from
making their doomed trip to the so-called
“Carnival of Horrors.” It’s a terrible
shame - if they’d listened to the stories
of this place about how unnatural and evil it
could be...They might still be alive today.
Like all the best urban explorers, they arrived
at the woods near the abandoned theme park in
the dead of night. They ignored the signs warning
them about everything from structural instability,
to dangerous wild animals, to asbestos.
Nothing would keep them out. Nothing.
They reached the abandoned theme park not long
after, though it was a mere shell of its former
self. During the several decades of abandonment,
nature had reclaimed it. The ferris wheel was
covered in overgrown ivy and the carnival
stands were blanketed with mold. As the duo
swept through the grounds with their flashlights
and cameras, they saw a faded sign that bore the
words “Thriller Chiller” - next to the rusty
skeleton of what had once been the park’s most
popular roller coaster. They also
took their time to marvel at the
exceptionally creepy-looking Tunnel of
Love, the broken down House of Mirrors,
and a huge, grinning statue of the
park’s former mascot, Happy Hippo.
This theme park was like something
out of a nightmare, which, naturally,
made it potential video gold. But as the
excited duo wandered further into the park,
they couldn’t help but notice the quiet,
tinny carnival music. Music that seemed to
be drawing them closer. Michael asked Jay if
he could hear the strange, impossible music,
and felt a chill creep in when he answered
that he did. Could all of the stories be true?
They were lost in thought, but their
legs kept moving. They were getting
closer to something now. They could feel a
presence. And was that music getting louder?
An instant later, though, another sound
cut through the silence - BANG! BANG!
It echoed out through the still night
air. Birds flew from their perches
in the trees. Jay and Michael
both fell to the ground, dead,
their heads taken off by the fifty caliber rounds
of a highly-trained Mobile Task Force Sniper on
the payroll of the SCP Foundation. Their recording
equipment, along with their bodies, were taken and
destroyed. Any trace of them was scrubbed from the
internet. It may seem a little harsh, but a bullet
to the head is a much kinder fate than what would
have awaited these two if they’d kept walking.
That’s because the Carnival of Horrors is
no dark fairytale. The rumors are all true,
and something really is waiting in the dark.
That’s why this abandoned theme park is known
to the SCP Foundation as SCP - 823, a Euclid
class anomaly with a violent history. What’s
even more unnerving is that the researchers
studying 823 have repeatedly implored the O5
Council to increase the park’s classification to
Keter and allocate more resources for containment,
only to be denied. But after you’ve heard
about the horrors that unfolded there,
and the danger it poses, you’ll
probably take the researchers’ side.
The park is divided into two different zones:
The Yellow Zone and the Red Zone. There are to
be at least six members of Foundation
personnel present in the Yellow Zone
at all times to ensure that no civilians
wander in. Our two urban explorers earned
themselves a death sentence not just by
wandering into the Yellow Zone, but passing
dangerously close to the Red Zone. This is
the true epicenter of the park’s dangerous,
anomalous activity. It’s a place so hazardous
that anyone entering, whether they’re a civilian
or a member of Foundation staff, is to be executed
at a distance by sniper fire without hesitation.
Once upon a time, though nobody knows exactly
when, there was a theme park that seemed no
different to any other. Eager children and
thrill-seeking teens arrived by the busload,
ready to stuff their faces with cotton candy
and corn dogs, and then reverse the process
on a vast array of rollercoasters. But even then
during these good times, there was something dark
lurking behind the cheerful facade. Little by
little everyone, visitors and employees alike,
started falling victim to strange and horrific
accidents around the park. Of course, when it
comes to theme parks, accidents come with the
territory, but none like this. Here are just a
handful of the horrific and mysterious deaths that
occurred while the park was open. So strap in,
because just like a roller coaster,
this isn’t for the faint of heart.
A pair of young lovebirds decided they wanted
to enjoy the romance of the Tunnel of Love.
The two sat in a swan-shaped boat as
they were ferried through darkened
passageways. Anyone would assume that they
were having a great time, but at some point,
terrible shrieks of pain and fear began
to echo through the ride. Attendants,
confused and terrified, stopped the ride and
found that the screaming persisted. Just some
stupid teens playing a prank, they figured, and
started the ride again. But when the swan-shaped
boat finally exited the Tunnel of Love, the
park employees were greeted to a horrifying
sight: The two teens, dead, their bodies
somehow fused together at multiple points.
Another unlucky customer met a gruesome fate
inside the House of Mirrors. They entered,
but while inside, they were stalked
by a mysterious, carnivorous,
humanoid entity known as Subject 79. The customer
was pursued and eventually caught by Subject 79,
and brutally dismembered. Some parts of the body
were fused to the House of Mirrors’ interior while
others - like the right arm - were never found.
This customer actually survived their ordeal - and
whether that’s a happy ending is up to you.
But it wasn’t just the customers at the park
who were in danger. A 23-year-old park employee
working a summer job collapsed while entertaining
children dressed as the park’s cheerful mascot,
Happy Hippo. It wasn’t uncommon for people to
get overheated and collapse in the heavy suits
on hot days, but one thing was different here:
He was screaming, crying, and trying
desperately to remove his mask.
People rushed to help, but nobody could get the
suit off, and he was declared dead soon after.
When he was eventually cut out of
the suit, coroners found that the
employee had choked to death. His mouth,
trachea, and lungs were filled with a
fibrous substance later determined to be
identical to the stuffing of his costume.
An intense roller coaster known as the Thriller
Chiller was a magnet for horrific accidents,
which became more violent and intense
over time. The first accident seemed
like a typical theme park tragedy - A safety
harness failed dropping a rider fifteen feet
during an inverted loop. They landed on the
track below, breaking their neck and skull,
causing instant death. While this
was a tragedy, it wasn’t exactly
anomalous. But the next major accident on
the ride was an entirely different story.
This time, fifteen people met with disaster
while riding the Thriller Chiller roller
coaster. Starting from the front and moving
back one car at a time, each group of riders was
decapitated by blunt force trauma. A new pair of
decapitations appeared to happen at every turn and
loop on the ride. Forensic scientists still have
no idea how this could have possibly occurred.
Despite all of these disasters, the park was only
finally abandoned after a day known as “Bloody
Sunday”, when the anomalous powers of the location
reached a twenty year peak. It’s believed that 231
people were killed during the carnage of that day,
and another seven were horribly maimed. The SCP
Foundation contained the Carnival of Horrors not
long after, but the mysterious deaths didn’t even
end there. Foundation Mobile Task Force Rho-71,
also known as the Origami Toads, were sent in to
assess containment procedures and discover the
source of all the anomalous deaths. They were
unsuccessful though, and instead they merely added
to the list, in exceptionally horrifying ways.
One agent was found dead, surrounded by empty
grenades and bullet casings. It appeared he’d
removed the explosive propellant from
all of his ballistics and consumed it,
dying in the process. Another was found with
his jaw broken, having apparently pulled out
and inhaled his own teeth, and dying of the
resulting internal damage. The commander got
the worst fate of all - so horrifying, in fact,
that we can’t tell you the full details. All
you need to know is that something was shoved
into his brain that really didn’t belong there.
The Foundation considered having the entire
park destroyed with a massive airstrike,
courtesy of the Mobile Task Force Nu-7, aka Hammer
Down. However, the O5 Council denied this request,
on the basis that the park was too close
to populated land, they’d have no plausible
cover story for the bombing, and they don’t even
really know if blowing up the park would prevent
anomalous activity from occurring. The Carnival
of Horrors is here to stay, folks, the Foundation
just hopes to keep it from getting new visitors.
So then back to why the researchers want this
place upgraded to Keter. After all, these
classifications aren’t about how dangerous
an anomaly is - they’re about how difficult and
complicated they are to contain. But here’s the
problem - according to researchers,
the Red Zone - where the dangerous,
anomalous activity is at its peak - isn’t bound to
one fixed position. It’s changed position at least
three times already, and even worse, it appears
to be growing. Not seeming so Euclid class now,
is it? After all, you might not even need to
visit the Carnival of Horrors to be in grave
danger. If it keeps growing then someday soon,
the Carnival of Horrors may be visiting you…
SCP Foundation agents stationed at Area 37
had intercepted chatter from a normally closed
communication system in a nearby city.
To anyone else, the calls that the Foundation
were eavesdropping would seem innocent - even
boring, but the Foundation immediately recognized
the coded language being used.
They were listening to communications between
underground cells of The Serpent’s Hand
- a dangerous paramilitary organization that
stands in opposition to everything the Foundation
is trying to do.
Once deciphered, the Serpent’s Hand messages
revealed plans for killing Foundation personnel,
breaking into containment sites, and releasing
anomalous creatures and objects into the world
- pretty standard stuff for the Foundation’s
least-favorite, anomaly-loving insurgents.
But they kept using one code that even the
Foundation didn’t have any intel on - they
kept asking about the condition of The Sisters.
Fate has a funny way of sneaking up on you
though, and in time, they would know more
about the powerful, sadistic, reality-warping
beings known as The Sisters than they could
have possibly imagined.
But what they would eventually learn was not
the kind of data that anyone would ever want
to have.
After intercepting clear lines of communication
from a local Serpent’s Hand cell, triangulating
the location of their compound was child’s
play, and Mobile Task Forces were dispatched
from Area 37 with orders to neutralize the
potential threat before they could mount an
attack on a facility.
Just when the Serpent’s Hands least expected
it, they had heavily-armed Foundation soldiers
kicking down their doors, crashing through
windows, and rappelling down from the ceiling.
As expected, the Serpent’s Hand put up a
fight, but thanks to their superior training
and the element of surprise, the Foundation’s
Mobile Task Forces came out on top.
They were able to capture fifteen surviving
members of the group for interrogation, as
well as a collection of anomalous objects
being stored by the group.
Among them were a small wooden loom, an enamel
needle, and a glass eye.
When the task force obtained these seemingly
mundane items, a haunted-looking Serpent’s
Hand began laughing wildly.
He kept repeating, “You have no idea what
you’re getting yourselves into...”
Nobody knew just how right this man was.
Not yet, anyway.
Congratulating themselves on a job well done,
the Mobile Task Forces hauled their captives
and the new anomalous items back to Area 37
- a heavily isolated Foundation site that
specializes in the early containment of anomalous
objects for initial observation and study.
The objects hadn’t displayed any anomalous
properties in transit - maybe the Serpent’s
Hand was lying and these weren’t dangerous
items at all, or it was actually just a pile
of junk.
Either way, they were sent to a Foundation
researcher on site to conduct preliminary
tests.
The loom, the needle, and the glass eye were
laid out across the table for observation,
when suddenly, the attending researcher felt
a dark presence looming behind him.
He turned, with sweat beading on his brow,
and saw three humanoid, translucent figures
floating in the air behind him.
They would soon become known as SCP - 1765
One, Two, and Three.
The researcher could feel the power emanating
from these silhouettes - reality seemed to
bend and shimmer around them, the way heat
distorts the air into a mirage.
He could tell right away that they were powerful
reality-warpers.
Even in their brief time communicating with
the researcher, One, Two, and Three displayed
both intelligence and unique personalities.
One was clearly the ringleader - displaying
an articulate command of language.
Two displayed a more mischievous side, speaking
with a cockney accent and had a tendency towards
creepy giggling.
Three was the least communicative of them
all - preferring to speak in short, simple
sentences, often consisting of just single
words.
Though of course, actions speak far louder
than words - and it didn’t take long for
the Sisters to define themselves with their
actions.
One told the scared and confused researcher
that they’d been observing the SCP Foundation
for quite some time, and that they deeply
admired the Foundation’s adherence to the
scientific method.
Of course, the researcher wasn’t so much
“flattered” by the Sister’s statement
as they were “afraid for their life.”
They tried to call security for backup, but
found that their tongue was withering and
turning into a shrivelled, blackened husk
in their mouth.
The Sisters didn’t like to be interrupted.
As the tongueless researcher slowly collapsed
in front of them, the Sisters explained the
purpose of their visit - They wished to assist
the Foundation in their quest for knowledge,
and, as such, they would conduct a number
of experiments on their behalf.
They would then happily share the resulting
data with the Foundation to compare notes.
One expressed optimism, saying that she believed
they were about to embark
on a beautiful scientific
relationship.
The reality couldn’t be further from the
truth.
The Sisters began their work, moving rapidly
around the facility, bending and twisting
reality wherever they went.
They circled Area 37, marking it as separate
from the rest of the world it inhabited.
Area 37 no longer belonged to planet earth
- it belonged to the Sisters.
It was their private experimentation lab,
filled with live and unwilling guinea pigs.
The Foundation attempted to retake the facility
by force, sending Mobile Task Force Iota-6,
also known as the Canvas Cats, into the belly
of the beast, but they never returned.
In addition to changing the fabric of reality
itself, they also altered the physical structure
of Area 37 to better serve their experimental
designs.
It was divided into four sections, marked
A, B, C, and D, each with its own unique purpose.
Section A - which had formerly been Area 37’s
storekeeping, mess hall, and dormitories - had
been the least affected by the Sisters’
attacks on reality.
The biggest alterations were the appearance
of two large, metal vats situated in the east
corner of the mess hall, a monitoring station
connected to other sections of Area 37 that
replaced the storekeeping zones, and an imposing
marble sign hanging above the dormitories
that reads “CONTROL GROUP.”
A quick refresher from science class, the
control group in an experiment is the group
that isn’t subjected to the experimental
effect the others are, so they can be used
as a benchmark to measure against.
The same was true here - the prisoners in
the control group were the safest of all,
but they were forced to do something almost
as bad, they had to watch the horrors playing
out across the rest of the facility.
One of the Sisters would occasionally return
to this section to oversee the feeding of
the control subjects, and to encourage them
to take part in the observation of their unlucky
peers.
Section B - which had formerly been Area 37’s
outer grounds and sports facilities - had
been transformed into the center of a localized
spatial-temporal abnormality.
In layman’s terms, this meant that its size,
climate, atmospheric composition, pressure,
and temporal flow were all subject to constant
changes based on the whims of Sister Number
One - who oversaw all the experiments performed
in Section B.
For those unfortunate enough to be trapped
in Section B, SCP-1765-1 was their god.
But she didn’t subject them to her whims
randomly.
No, in her own words, the purpose of Section
B was to delve into the effects of repetitive
action performed under unusual conditions
on the human psyche.
For example, one experiment was set up to
test the physical and mental fortitude of
a Researcher, a Field Agent, and a sanitation
worker.
The trio were confined in a sports center
and ordered to measure the length of every
single pipe and the angle at which each connected
to others with nothing more than a wrench,
a ruler, a brown paper pad and a ballpoint
pen.
The task was an arduous one taking over ten
hours.
And as soon as the subjects were done, One
restructured the sports center and ordered
them to perform the task again.
The same happened another 459 times before
One finally concluded the experiment, leaving
the subjects with broken bodies and minds
in the aftermath.
Section C - which had previously been the
facility’s main office block - exhibited
a similar level of anomalous activity to Section
B, except that it was the domain of the more
sadistic and mischievous Sister Number Two.
Her main area of scientific interest was studying
group dynamics and interpersonal relationships
during extreme conditions
- very extreme conditions.
For one experiment, the office block had been
transformed into a kind of football stadium,
with the goal posts removed and replaced by
concrete bunkers.
The two teams were the captured Serpent Hand
members, and the members of MTF Iota-6, fresh
off their attempt to retake the site.
The two groups were forced into a deadly game
with incomprehensible rules - including rising
platforms and hooded figures throwing fiery
projectiles into the crowd, trying to incinerate
the players.
But victory didn’t lead to safety, as the
winners of the game were crushed to death
with giant metal hammers, just for the fun
of it.
Two didn’t even try to pretend that this
act had a valid scientific justification.
Section D - which had once been the facility’s
high-risk containment area - was now the strangest
and most mysterious section of all.
Under the charge of the equally peculiar and
enigmatic Sister Number Three, this area appeared
physically unchanged from its state prior
to the arrival of the Sisters.
Temporally, however, Section D was the most
warped of them all.
It existed in a kind of temporal bubble, outside
of the rest of our reality’s timeline, giving
Three a frightening amount of control over
all that went on in her domain outside of
time.
There she was performing the most strange
and incomprehensible experiment of all.
The subject was the former Site Director of
Area 37.
He was brought to a table, and asked to choose
between two different flavors of ice cream
that were presented to him.
Sounds simple enough, so then why is this
the worst of them all?
Because the Site Director is caught in a time
loop.
He’s been choosing between various flavors
of ice cream for over ten thousand hours,
and he doesn’t even seem to know.
Three’s only comment on the matter?
“Delicious.”
All attempts to liberate
the unfortunate inhabitants
of Area 37 have failed miserably.
The Sisters don’t appear to operate on any
form of logic or empathy, and thus, cannot
be reasoned with.
With talks having failed and Mobile Task Force
Iota-6’s attempt to retake the site ending
in disaster, the only solution left was to
create a guarded perimeter around the area,
using technology like the Scranton Reality
Anchor to fight back against any potential
escape by the Sisters.
The Sisters are potentially so dangerous that
if they ever truly set their minds to leaving,
it’s considered acceptable to detonate the
facility’s on-site nuclear warhead in hopes
of finally putting a stop to them.
In the meantime, the Foundation has built
giant external servers for processing the
vast quantities of research data the Sisters
are constantly sending from their horrifying
experiments.
Sadly for the inhabitants of Area 37, their
grim fate continues to this day.
The experiments never stop, and the subjects
of said experiments seem to be condemned to
the eternal torment of SCP - 1765.
In a way, their unwilling sacrifice protects
us all - because if ever the Sisters were
interested in performing experiments on a
larger sample size…
Well, all we can do is hope we end up in the
control group.
It’s a perfect day for a wedding.
On a warm spring afternoon, a beautiful bride
and a handsome groom are exchanging the special
rings they had custom designed and made for
each other.
As they take turns placing the rings on each
other's fingers, a man standing at the end
of the wedding party steps out of position.
He approaches the groomsman next to him and
reaches into his jacket, taking out a pair
of pliers that he hands to the groomsman.
The groomsman happily takes the tool and then,
without any hesitation, shoves the pliers
into his mouth and begins removing his teeth
one by one.
When he is finished, he hands the bloody teeth
to the man along with the pliers.
The man then goes to the next groomsman who
repeats the same process.
He continues going down the line until all
of the groomsmen and bridesmaids have removed
their teeth, seemingly without pain or resistance.
The man then approaches the bride and groom.
He hands each of them half of the pile of
teeth, which they gladly accept.
They then begin to eat the teeth without delay,
seemingly not bothered by the intense damage
they’re causing to their own teeth and jaws
by doing so.
The man watches as the groom moves the priest
who was officiating the wedding aside.
As the entire church looks on in joy, the
groom opens his mouth and the deafening sound
of cicadas are heard.
This is only the beginning of what the SCP
Foundation has labeled an SCP-2852 event,
a terrifying and little understood phenomenon
that is better known by the nickname of the
anomalous creature responsible for them…
Cousin Johnny.
The Foundation had been trying to contain
Cousin Johnny for decades - not that it’d
ever done them any good.
Johnny is a Keter-Class anomaly that’s thus
far proven impossible to contain.
This is an entity so dangerous and volatile
that three different Mobile Task Forces are
devoted to detecting and disrupting its activities
- MTF Upsilon-36, aka The Party Crashers.
MTF Upsilon-52, aka Cater Duty.
And MTF Upsilon-99, aka The Altar Boys.
But so far all the Foundation has been able
to really do is swoop in afterwards and do
their best to pick up the pieces of people’s
shattered lives.
Cousin Johnny has so far been observed to
only operate in the North American subcontinent,
and only seems to appear at Anglican or Catholic
baptisms, weddings, and funerals.
However, Foundation operatives charged with
keeping a lid on Cousin Johnny harbor the
hidden fear that he may one day expand his
hunting grounds, and wreak terror worldwide.
If Johnny became multinational
or multi denominational,
his violence, insanity, and pure evil may
truly become impossible to minimize, so compatible
communities are constantly monitored for increased
levels of juvenile delinquency, sterility,
domestic violence, and divorce.
After all this, you’re probably wondering:
Who or what actually is Cousin Johnny, and
how does he cause so much horrific tragedy?
At face value, nothing about the appearance
of Cousin Johnny would suggest an anomalous
nature, or even any sort of danger.
He appears to be a middle-aged white male,
often with scruffy hair and a beard.
On a cellular level too, Cousin Johnny appears
all too human, but when you look at his physiology
it’s a whole different story.
Cousin Johnny
has no identifiable organs whatsoever
- his body is made out of a fibrous muscular
tissue.
The only exceptions are his teeth and hair,
which are made of a kind of chitin - a key
component of insect exoskeletons, such as
those possessed by cicadas.
Johnny’s eyes are the first clue that something
is off about him.
From a distance they appear perfectly normal,
but up close, they’re glassy and dead.
This is because his eyes aren’t actually
attached to any nerves inside his head.
With no nervous system or vocal chords, Johnny’s
ability to see, move, and talk defy any kind
of logical explanation.
His speech will seem completely normal to
the people under his spell, but to anyone
else, it comes out as complete nonsense, often
described as word salad.
If people in attendance are briefed in advance
about this phenomenon, whatever hypnotic ability
causes them to hear his sounds as intelligible
words won’t work, and they’ll be aware
of how nonsensical it all sounds.
But of course, that doesn’t mean they’re
safe.
Cousin Johnny appears at family gatherings
and religious rituals, and immediately, he’ll
be treated as though he’s always been there.
You know your Cousin Johnny, right?
You go way back.
Or at least, you’re pretty sure you do.
Nothing will appear unnatural about his sudden
presence.
In fact, if you’re one of the victims of
one of his incidents, chances are, you’ll
actually find yourself taking a shine to Cousin
Johnny.
Sure his sense of humor is a little crude
and raunchy, but you can’t help but enjoy
his company.
He’s a fun guy to be around, and after all,
he’s family!
As previously mentioned, he’ll only appear
at three different kinds of events: Baptisms,
Weddings, and Funerals, and only at those
that are affiliated with either the Catholic
or Anglican religions.
The SCP Foundation has classified baptisms
that Cousin Johnny attends as Blue Level Events,
Weddings are known as White Level Events,
and Funerals are Black Level Events - with
each one escalating in severity, violence,
and horror.
First, Baptisms - the Blue Level Events.
In these events, Cousin Johnny will appear
and begin to act as a third godparent, despite
there traditionally only being two.
As the infant is lowered into the holy water,
the entirety of their top layer of skin will
come off, like a molting snake.
Despite looking horrific, this apparently
causes no harm to the child.
The godparents will then eat this discarded
skin, as though it’s the most normal thing
in the world.
After this, the family will leave the church
together, and Cousin Johnny will leave with
them.
He won’t appear at any subsequent celebrations
of the child’s baptism.
If this is where it ended, it’d be extremely
gross - but not exactly a living nightmare.
Of course this is just the beginning of the
terror.
Following Cousin Johnny’s appearance at
the baptism, the child’s risk of dying in
the next six months skyrockets, and if they
survive, they’re at an increased risk of
becoming unstable and violent later on in
life.
Their parents and godparents will both become
unable to conceive any further children, and
are likely to be found dead from drowning
within five years of the event.
Those who were only tangentially involved
in the baptism ritual have a massively increased
chance of failed pregnancies, or - if they
do conceive - they may become a danger to
their offspring.
Children who live through Blue Level Events
and survive past adolescence, will experience
adverse side effects when encountering the
songs of cicadas well into adulthood - from
experiencing physical sickness to going through
dangerous psychotic episodes.
Weddings, or White Level Events, are more
complex and severe.
In this case, Cousin Johnny will insert himself
into the wedding as a groomsman, and the most
horrifying events will begin to take place
after the vows have been exchanged.
Johnny will provide various implements that
allow the bridesmaids and groomsmen to remove
their teeth, which are then given to the bride
and groom to eat - which they do, causing
severe damage to their own teeth in the process.
The groom will then vocalize an unknown cicada
call at an incredible volume, as loud as 140
decibels in some instances, rendering the
bride and everyone else near the altar completely
deaf.
At the wedding reception, where everyone is
continuing to behave as if northing out of
the ordinary is happening, Cousin Johnny will
ruin things further by giving the best man’s
speech.
The speech is more of his typical complete
nonsense, though if you’re there you’ll
never realize this, and think that this is
the best speech you’ve ever heard, with
some in the audience laughing hysterically
while others cry uncontrollably.
Once his speech is done, he’ll present a
gift to the newly married couple…
3.5 kilograms of human hair in various colors,
13 deceased specimens of a certain cicada
known as Linne's cicada, and 23 human teeth
in a cardboard box.
DNA tests on all gifts have been inconclusive
as to their origin.
Much like many celebrity marriages, unions
that occurred during White Level events never
last, and all end up divorced within two years
- often as a result of domestic violence,
and any children born during their brief marriage
will be violent and unstable.
But it’s not just the wedding party that
gets to experience the fun of a visit from
Cousin Johnny.
All married individuals who attended the wedding
will find that they are unable to conceive
children, despite no biological indicators
of infertility.
Any children present at the White Level Event
will show no interest in romance throughout
their life, and often die tragically before
reaching the age of eighteen.
Finally, and most horrifying of all, are funerals
- or Black Level Events.
While Blue and White Level Events can potentially
be disrupted before they are completed, lessening
or preventing the horrific results, there
is as yet no way to stop or prevent a Black
Level Event at any stage.
Any attempts to prevent Cousin Johnny from
entering the church or funeral home will lead
to him simply manifesting inside.
Once in the room where the funeral is taking
place, Cousin Johnny will first take up the
role of eulogizer and begin speaking his standard
nonsense to the attendants.
The person who was emotionally closest to
the departed will then open the casket, if
this was not already an open casket funeral,
and will then produce a large knife.
It’s unknown where the knives come from
as they’re not present before the event
and they disappear after.
The funeral attendees will then use the knife
on their wrists and sometimes throats, draining
their blood into the coffin.
Many lose more than enough blood to result
in death, but none ever die from this, nor
do they seem to feel any pain from their wounds.
As the attendees take turns bleeding into
the coffin, Cousin Johnny continues his eulogy
which eventually evolves into a cicada song,
the kind sung by Linne’s cicada males.
The attendants sing the same song back to
him in a kind of call and response.
Cousin Johnny will then approach the coffin
and vomit in a mixture of blood, wood pulp,
and dead cicadas.
The funeral will then proceed as normal, and
the blood, vomit, and cicada filled casket
is then taken to the cemetery and buried.
Black Level Events will usually end with the
body being interred in the ground, but if
there’s a wake after the funeral, the horrors
of the Black Level Event will continue.
At the wake, Cousin Johnny will climb on top
of a table, lie down, and encourage the other
attendants to devour him, which they do - all
while he continues to talk his nonsense.
Until there is nothing left.
Much like Blue and White Level events, being
in attendance leads to horrific after-effects.
All participants who experience this event
will separate from their family through either
suicide, moving, or divorce.
Every individual present at the event will
also find that they are no longer able to
produce offspring, and couples present may
also fall victim to incidences of domestic
violence, often involving cannibalism, that
usually leave one or both participants dead,
while six out of ten children involved will
attempt to murder one or both of their parents
before they turn eighteen.
These Black Level Events are so horrible for
all involved, that any members of the specialized
Cousin Johnny Mobile Task Forces that happen
to witness such an event are treated with
Class-A amnestics before they are transferred
to another task force or retire, to ensure
that they don’t have to live with the memories
of what they saw.
Prior to that, they are closely monitored
for any strange or anti-social behavior to
make sure they weren’t affected by the event.
And they aren’t the only SCP Foundation
staff at risk of having been impacted by Cousin
Johnny.
It is theorized that as many as a third of
Catholic and Anglican D-Class personnel were
involved in a Black-Level event at some point,
and were driven to madness and violence by
their fateful brushes with the strange relative
that no one knows.
So next time you’re at a baptism, or a wedding,
or a funeral, stay vigilant.
Keep an eye on the other guests.
And always ask yourself: Do you really have
a Cousin Johnny?
You hear their footsteps coming down
the halls. Or are those your own?
Can you even tell the difference? You can tell
they’re getting closer and you can feel the hate,
the rage. You turn, shaking, and
finally see them standing right
in front of you. But in that moment, you
might as well be looking into a mirror.
And who knows? Perhaps you are. You just don’t
seem to remember having so many reflections...
Have you ever heard the saying “You
are your own worst enemy?” Of course,
it isn’t usually meant literally. But what if it
was? What if you had to fight a monster…that was
you? All of your flaws are reflected back
at you. Your strengths, your weaknesses,
your deepest fears, with no way to escape
except a battle to the death. Either way,
you’re not making it out alive. It’s just a
matter of which version of you survives. But
this isn’t a thought experiment. No, according to
the findings of the SCP Foundation, it’s very much
a reality. There is a place where this nightmare
comes to life, and it is known as SCP-1919.
SCP-1919 is a hotel and converted mansion, built
in the early 20th century. From the outside,
it looks pretty much like it
did when it was first built,
and it almost looks like a comfortable
place to stay… if you ignore the eastern
side of the building that has
sunk partially into the ground.
The inside, however, is a different story, where
it’s clear the ravages of time have taken their
toll. The floorboards and ceilings are rotting,
collapsing in on themselves, and the rooms are
filled with debris. It’s deadly enough to explore
the hotel for these reasons alone, but this is
only the beginning of the danger for a person
inside. In order to determine just how dangerous
it is for either one person or group to enter the
structure, the SCP Foundation planned a series of
research expeditions into the abandoned building,
led by Foundation scientist Dr. Limkiewicz.
The first expedition seemed relatively
normal, at least it did at the start. A
39-year-old Caucasian D-Class male known as
D7 was sent into the structure with a camera
and a communications system, guided remotely by
Dr. Limkiewicz, or Dr. L, and another operative,
a former head of the MTF Tau-11 “Youth Hostiles”
who is referred to in this file only as T11.
When he arrived at the building, D7 was
unable to get inside through the front
door or windows. After several minutes of
trial and error, he was finally able to
get in through the western entrance. Dr. L
picked up a strange, high-pitched whistling
noise upon D7’s entrance into the building,
but it quickly faded away and was disregarded
by T11. D7 discovered a torn painting, a
portrait of a young woman with red hair.
Next to the portrait, shallow scratches
could be seen in the wall, the floor,
and parts of the ceiling. Suddenly, D7 ducked
into a hiding place, alarmed. He, and the other
two operatives listening to his audio feed could
hear heavy breathing… and it didn’t belong to D7.
Dr. L recommended that D7 evacuate the
building at this sign of another entity
inside, but T11 overruled, ordering him to
disregard that instruction and continue his
investigation. D7 was told to stay at a safe
distance from whatever was inside with him,
and attempt to capture it on video. D7 turned
off his flashlight in order to better hide, but
T11 commanded that he turn it back on. Whatever
was caught in its beam of light was difficult for
the camera to see, but it threw D7 into a panic
and he began to run in the opposite direction.
When prompted to explain what he
saw, D7 simply said: “It was me!”
D7 ran through the dark, panting with fear
and exertion. Unable to see where his feet
were landing, he tripped over something
and came crashing onto the ground,
dropping the video camera. This allowed the
observing officers to finally see what D7
was so frightened by, and it became
clear just why D7 was so terrified.
A man, identical looking to D7, approached from
the end of the hallway, making its way toward
the real D7. It was followed by another
man who also resembled D7, and another,
all running toward the original.
They all looked exactly like him,
with a few notable differences. They
were dressed in the same uniform,
with the same build and the same features,
but each had something slightly off about him.
One was missing eyelids,
another had malformed hands,
and the third had its lips fused together
into a fleshy mass beneath its nose.
Dr. L moved to cut the camera feed, but T11
demanded that it be kept running. D7 couldn’t
be seen by the camera, but the microphone picked
up the sounds of flesh and cloth being torn, along
with pained, panicked screams as the duplicates
set upon him. After a moment, the screaming
stopped. Two hours later, the camera was broken,
and the expedition brought to a troubling end.
This was the Foundation’s first glimpse
at the creatures inside of SCP-1919,
and it was not pretty. It did, however, allow them
to begin understanding the nature of the building,
and what happens when a person goes inside.
It appears that when a human enters the hotel,
several humanoid creatures manifest throughout the
building. These creatures look like the subject,
and are equipped with the same clothing or items
that the subject brought inside with them. Though
they are nearly mirror images of the subject, they
are always slightly warped in a variety of ways.
These have included changes to limb and digit
length, joint mobility, sealed nostrils,
lengthened jaws hanging loose and limp,
missing eyelids, and lips that are fused
together. These creatures are highly aggressive
toward the structure of the building itself,
as well as to the subject that they resemble.
They do not, however, attack each other. They
appear to operate with a hive mind, exhibiting
swarm intelligence like that of an ant colony.
Once they have been spawned by
the entrance of a new person,
they will not stop until said person
either escapes the building or is killed.
After the unfortunate end to the first
expedition, the Foundation prepped for
a second trip inside. This time, three men were
sent in with Dr. L’s guidance, known as D3, D4,
and D9. Video cameras were sewn into their clothes
to leave their hands free and to help avoid some
of the issues that came up during the first
expedition. This small team was sent in with
the orders to terminate the remaining copies of
D7, and further examine the hotel’s interior.
Upon opening the door to the building, they
were immediately attacked by one of D7’s copies,
which D9 was able to quickly dispatch
by firing his weapon at its head. Next,
after a great deal of reluctance,
the three men entered the building
where they spotted something unusual
inside. Dr. L was horrified when the
camera feed revealed seventeen discarded
video cameras spread across the floor.
They didn’t have much time to
react to this new discovery,
however, because two doubles, one
mirroring D7 and another mirroring D9,
emerged from the wall and began to attack.
Dr. L ordered the team to take shelter,
then called the team of guards outside of
the hotel’s perimeter. They were ordered
to begin an immediate full perimeter lockdown,
preventing the doubles from leaving the hotel.
D3, D4, and D9 attempted to make their
way to a safe corner of the building,
but found themselves met with a murderous double
at every turn. At this point, Dr. L began to hear
an unusual sound over the microphone feed, a
high-pitched whine like that of a dentist’s
drill. The operatives on the ground couldn’t hear
a thing, but on Dr. L’s end it was deafening.
As the team proceeded deeper into the hotel,
they became overcome with a strange feeling
of foreboding. Dr. L ordered them to turn
on their flashlights, but they refused and
begged Dr. L to keep quiet. When prompted
to explain, D9 said: “she can hear you.”
The operatives stopped responding,
but their camera feeds caught a faint,
glowing white light coming from
beneath a door. The door opened,
and the light flooded the camera, making
the images it captured hard to decipher.
Just a few frames of a quick-moving female
silhouette were captured before the cameras
cut to static. The bodies of D3, D4, and D9
were never recovered, nor were their cameras.
A third expedition was also sent into SCP-1919,
but very little is known about what occurred
during it. The video transcript is highly
classified and only those present for its events,
or approved to research SCP-1919, have access
to it. An update to the SCP-1919 file following
Expedition Three though, indicates that
new information was revealed about the
hotel during the excursion. According to the
file update, there is some kind of being at
the center of the location which is causing all
of the other creatures, the doubles, to appear.
The only information available about this
being is the use of the word “her” in the
official Foundation log about SCP-1919. This
seems to match up with the last moments of
the operatives in Expedition Two, when they
told Dr. L that “she can hear you” and the
few frames of a female figure that were
captured by their cameras. Nothing else
is known that has been made available
to anyone outside a very select few.
Only the original report exists, and all
other copies of it have been destroyed.
The Foundation has undertaken special containment
procedures to make sure that none of the entities
from inside the hotel escape, whether they are
the “evil twins” spawned by humans entering
the building, or the mysterious female being at
the center of the entire disturbing phenomenon.
The Foundation has classified SCP-1919
as Euclid and a two kilometer radius
must be maintained around SCP-1919, with all
roads leading to the building are blocked or
diverted so that no vehicles are able to
reach it. This perimeter is guarded by a
set of at least forty armed and armored guards
at any given time. As it has been determined
that the doubles spawned by 1919 are equipped
with whatever the human they are copying has,
no one is allowed to enter the hotel
with body armor or weapons of any kind.
Anyone that approaches the perimeter that is
not part of an official expedition team will
be immediately terminated. No new expeditions
teams are allowed to enter the building unless
all doubles from the previous expedition
have been exterminated. In the event that
they cannot be exterminated, enough time
must elapse between expeditions that the
previous doubles have starved to death.
Though they do not seem to feel hunger,
the doubles do need to eat to survive, and
will die when left alone for long enough.
SCP-1919 has been sealed off from the rest of
the world, so that no hapless civilians can
wander inside and find themselves torn to
pieces by warped images of themselves. But
that comfort turns cold when you realize that
the SCP Foundation still does not understand
what causes these doubles to spawn. Is it
scientific? Supernatural? Or something else?
No one can be certain. Even more inexplicable
is the entity at the center of all this,
an unknown female presence capable of wreaking
frightening amounts of violence by turning
victims’ own images against them. What is the
purpose of these funhouse mirror nightmares?
Who is she, what is she, and what does she
want? Currently, the doubles have shown no
interest in leaving the hotel except to attack
intruders, and thanks to that fact, as well as
the reinforced perimeter outside, these copycats
have not appeared outside of the building itself.
But what happens if they do escape,
or if the entity that controls them
decides to make her home elsewhere? There
is no telling what could happen if this
dark power is allowed to move
beyond its current containment.
Are you prepared to fight a vision
of yourself, twisted almost beyond
recognition, lunging after you with wide
bulbous eyes, unnaturally long arms,
and a distended jaw hanging down below its
neck? Better hope you never have to find out.
In high school, the days tend to blend together
after a while. Math test, unrequited love,
annoying group project, stress, rinse, repeat.
Sometimes a big football game or a school dance,
or maybe a fight in the hallway
breaks up the monotony a bit,
but it’s normally pretty uneventful.
That’s always been fine by me. I’ve
never tried to be a popular kid or the center
of attention, I prefer to keep my head down,
work stage crew for the school plays, and just
hang out with the same small group of friends
I’ve known since we were little kids.
It was on one of these ordinary days,
in a long line of similarly ordinary days,
that something came to destroy the peaceful
high school existence I’d gotten used to. As
I sat in history class, passing notes with
my best friend Zach and ignoring a video about
the Civil War, I had no idea that I was about
to live through the worst day of my life. And I
would be one of the lucky ones; I’d survive. The
others…let’s just say they wouldn’t be so lucky.
I was just scribbling a response to Zach,
something about hanging out and playing
Xbox after school, when the PA system
crackled to life. Our principal’s voice
cut through the droning narration about
the Battle of Antietam as he spoke.
“Staff, this is a lockdown. Initiate
your lockdown procedures immediately. If you
are a visitor outside the building, please
leave the property immediately, and call 911.”
I assumed it was just another lockdown drill,
until I saw my teacher’s face. She looked pale,
her expression tight, like she was trying to hold
it together for our benefit. I could see her hands
shaking as she reached to turn off the video,
and when I heard the tremor in her voice I knew
for sure: she was terrified. This was not a drill.
As our teacher locked the door and we all
climbed under our desks to crouch in the
dark and wait out the lockdown, I could hear
my classmates whispering feverishly. Everyone
was trying to figure out what was going on.
Someone suggested a kid had brought a knife
to school. Someone wondered aloud if a threat
had been called in to the principal’s office.
Zach cracked a dumb joke about a mutated frog
escaping from the biology lab, when suddenly
a scream rang out, echoing down the hall.
Have you ever felt an entire room of people
holding their breath at once? I have.
We listened for the sound of fighting,
for gunshots, anything
...Nothing. And then another scream, louder,
closer, and longer than the last. It was a
scream of pure, unadulterated fear and pain
that dissolved into a wet gurgle that made
my stomach turn. Zach and I shared a look,
one that said, “whatever is going on,
it’s like nothing we’ve ever seen before.”
I could feel my chest tightening, and it was
getting harder to breathe. I tucked my head
between my knees, holding onto the back of my head
and trying to take in deep gulps of air. The room
felt as if it tilted on its side and I thought
I might pass out, when another sound brought me
back to earth. It was coming from the back wall
of the classroom, by the chalkboard. The sound of
liquid sloshing onto the floor, mixed with plaster
splintering apart and pieces clattering all over.
I tried to get a better look, but the
room was dark and I didn’t want to leave
the relative safety of my desk. If there
was someone, or something, coming into the
room…I didn’t want it to see me.
Zach had a better angle than me,
I could see him craning his neck to get a
better look, when he clapped a hand over
his mouth in shock. I heard him scream, muffled,
against his hand. What had he seen? What was it?
Before I could even ask, my teacher’s cry
ripped through the darkness and the silence.
“Get out! Get out!” She repeated over and over
again, and I could hear the raw desperation in her
voice. It was like someone ushering passengers
off of the sinking Titanic, someone who knows
there is no hope for them but hopes they can at
least save the children before it all goes down.
“Run! For the love of God just run!” Her voice
broke, from fear, from pain, or both, and the
sound was enough to get my legs working again. My
classmates had the same response, and we blindly
rushed for the door, flipping over desks and
knocking chairs to the side as we scrambled for
an exit. Zach grabbed my arm, and I held on tight,
afraid I would lose him in the chaos. Someone
unlocked the door and we poured out into the hall.
Just as I made it out of the door, I couldn’t
help but turn back and look. Call it morbid
curiosity, call it instinct, call it stupidity,
but I had to see what had happened. I turned
just in time to see a nightmare brought to life.
The wall was melting, covered in something thick,
black, and putrid. The smell invaded my nostrils
and I gagged on it. A wretched, grey arm had
its fingers wrapped around the teacher’s wrist,
skin peeling off to reveal muscle and bone.
It looked like it belonged to a corpse,
but it gripped her with inhuman strength. She
was pulling with all her might, but I watched
helplessly as the arm pulled her into the melted
wall like she weighed nothing, swallowing her body
and her screams with it. And then she was gone.
Zach tugged on my arm, hard, yanking
me into the hall.
“Come on man, run!”
He hadn’t seen what I’d seen, or
he would have realized that running
might not be enough. Whatever this thing
was, it didn’t play by any rules I knew.
Running was all we had right now, though, so we
ran. I looked around for a weapon, something,
anything I could use to defend myself, but I
couldn’t see anything that would help. Instead,
all I saw was the destruction the intruder
had left in its wake. All around me,
the halls I walked through every day were falling
to pieces. They weren’t just damaged. They were
coming apart at the seams. Lockers were warped
beyond recognition, walls completely dissolved,
sections of the floor reduced to
sizzling puddles of goo, and everywhere,
everything was covered in that same black slime.
It smelled worse than you can ever imagine. It
smelled like the complete loss of hope, like
the point of no return. It smelled like death.
We reached the end of the hall when I heard
something shifting behind us. I suddenly became
aware that we were alone. The sounds of frantic
footsteps, hushed whispers, doors slamming shut
and locking, had all quieted. Where was everyone?
I glanced over my shoulder, and saw one lone
figure shambling down the hall toward us. It was
far away, and I could scarcely make it out in the
darkness, but I could hear dripping, sizzling,
and the smell of decay grew stronger. That was
not a classmate or a teacher. Whatever it was, it
was taking people away, or killing them, I didn’t
know exactly what. But whatever it was doing
to everyone, Zach and I were next on its list.
The scariest part was how slowly it moved. Maybe
its legs were too rotten to move any faster,
joints disintegrating into useless mush, but
it seemed more deliberate than that. To me,
in my panic-clouded mind, it seemed that it
was taking its time. It didn’t need to rush,
it knew that, when it wanted to catch
its prey, it would. I couldn’t suppress
the sick feeling in my stomach this time,
I keeled over and vomited onto the floor.
When I looked up, Zach was beckoning to me
from just inside the doors to the auditorium.
“Come on! In here!”
He could have left me
behind for the intruder to take, tried to save
himself, and sacrifice the slow friend frozen in
place with terror, but here he was looking out
for me again. Even in this horrible situation,
I felt a surge of gratitude. I booked it
across the floor, forgetting for a moment
about the shuffling corpse making its way toward
us, and joined my best friend in the auditorium.
It was eerie in the dark, the curtain
soaking up and dampening sounds,
barely any light illuminating the normally
cheerful props and backdrops left from the
recent production of Alice in Wonderland. A once
friendly place felt twisted, like a mockery of
Wonderland with a monster stalking outside
and waiting to pounce. We sat on the stage,
listening to the sound of our labored breathing.
The air felt heavy, but I welcomed the smell of
paint and dust over the nauseating stench
that permeated the rest of the school.
“Are we the only ones left?” Zach whispered,
breaking the silence. He was the first one to say
what we were both thinking, what we both feared.
“No.” I said with false confidence. “I think some
of them got out, before…” I couldn’t finish the
sentence. “Somebody had to get out. It can’t
just be us.” I leaned my head against a giant
papier-mache toadstool, glad it was too dark for
Zach to see the tears filling my eyes.
“What was that thing?” He asked.
“Did you see it?” I sat up straighter.
I thought I was the only one who’d
gotten a look at the thing, however fleeting.
“No. But I heard it. And…smelled it.” He coughed.
It took me a while to answer his question.
Eventually, I found the word. “It’s evil.”
We sat in silence for a long while after that. I
don’t know exactly how long. Moments like that,
where at any second you could be lost forever,
time stretches out into something unrecognizable.
I was starting to think, foolishly, that we
might be in the clear, when I heard a strange
sound. It was a creaking, like footsteps on
an old wooden floor. I looked around for the
source of the noise, but I couldn’t see anything.
It sounded close, impossibly close. Creak. Creak.
One step then another. Where was that
coming from? There was no wood floor in
the hall, nothing above us.
By the time I understood,
it was too late. The top of a head, slimy, clammy
and grey, with tufts of limp white hair clinging
to the soft flesh began to emerge from the
stage where we sat. Eyes, hollow and dead,
but somehow alert and searching for us,
came next, followed by a gaping wound where
a nose should be, and a wide, toothless grin.
It looked almost like a person, but it was wrong.
Just wrong. Every cell in my body rejected it,
screaming at me with thousands of years of animal
instinct that I had to run. I grabbed Zach’s
arm and yanked, but he didn’t come with me.
I turned to look, and my heart jumped into my
throat. It had him. Its bony fingers had a hold
on his legs, and he was already halfway gone,
pulled into a slick black puddle in the stage.
His face was damp with tears, as the reality
of his fate set in. He grabbed my hand in his,
and squeezed. “Run.” Was all he could get out,
before the old man pulled him out of sight.
So I obeyed my best friend’s wish.
I ran, and I hid in the prop closet,
hand over my mouth to stifle my breathing.
Suddenly, there was a loud bang, and I heard
voices yelling. Something that sounded like a
gunshot. A blast of bright light. Then, a voice,
male and official-sounding, called out: “Is anyone
in here? You can come out, we’re with the police.”
I opened the closet door and peered out, to see
people in hazmat suits wielding bizarre weapons
and carrying devices I’d never seen before.
The man who had spoken approached me,
took my hand, and asked me if I’d seen anything. I
got the strong sense that I should definitely not
tell him what I’d seen. “No, sir,” I said.
He nodded. Whether he believed me or not,
he knew I wouldn’t say anything more.
“Gas leak.” He said. “It destroyed large
parts of the building. Highly dangerous.
We need to get you out of here.”
They took me home and I hugged my parents
tighter than I ever had before. That night,
the news covered the tragedy at my school.
The “gas leak” had taken dozens of lives
before the authorities had gotten there.
Everyone else can accept that story all
they want. I know the truth. I see it when
I close my eyes, imagine it standing over
me when I wake up in the dead of night.
Those hollow eyes, that horrible smile,
the stench of death and rot. It looked right
at me. It saw me. It wanted…I can’t let myself
think about what it wanted.
I don’t know exactly what I saw,
but I know a few things for certain: There was
no gas leak. Zach and the rest of the people
it took are gone. And, if that monster
ever escapes…it’s coming after me next.
Throwing indestructible lizards into vats
of acid, hunting strange chicken men through
forests in Ireland, arguing in Latin with
a man wearing a haunted Roman Centurion’s
helmet.
When you join the SCP Foundation, you might
be expecting high-octane drama all the time.
Especially with the name Street Sweepers,
you’d expect this Mobile Task Force to be
neck deep in some real action-packed street
racing.
Maybe you wouldn’t think that they’d be
tasked with driving all day every day in four-hour
shifts, tailing a semi-truck, all over Birmingham,
Alabama.
But as Agent Moore and his colleague pulled
into the layby behind the truck, neither of
them were ready for what they were about to
witness…
*
SCP-2590 was first discovered by the Foundation
at a routine traffic stop.
Investigating a totally different anomaly
in the Birmingham area, Agents Peters and
Smith had been posing as local police officers.
The Foundation had been trying to track down
an artifact that was supposedly being smuggled
across the US in the back of a non-descript
station wagon.
Peters and Smith had been allocated a pair
of beat-up old police cruisers which they’d
parked across the dirt road, fully blocking
any traffic from coming through.
It was several hours into their shift, when
the incident occurred, just at the point that
they were starting to lose focus.
Taking a look through the
suitcases and memorabilia
from a family’s trip to Disney World, Peters
had taken way too long to hear the noise of
the engine swelling behind him.
He spun around to see the hulking shape of
the semi-truck barreling straight towards
him, Agent Smith, and a family of five.
With only two seconds to react, he yelled
out at the top of his lungs and dived out
of the way, leaving the trunk of the car wide
open with five screams emerging from inside.
Smith, who had been sitting in one of the
cruisers, only just managed to get out before
the semi made contact.
Eyes closed, Agent Peters
waited for the inevitable
sound of screaming rubber, the bang of metal
on metal, and the shower of glass on asphalt.
But it never came.
When he opened his eyes, the station wagon
was still parked up in front of them, the
two police cruisers still blocking the road,
and all of the Disney merch still piled high
in the trunk.
The semi was driving off along the road on
the other side of their blockade, not a scratch
on it.
Without a moment's hesitation, Agent Smith,
who had kept his eyes open and witnessed the
whole thing, leaped into action.
He ordered his partner, still lying confused
in the dirt, to administer Class-A amnestics
to the family and call in for backup.
Agent Smith himself jammed his keys into the
ignition, twisted them so hard he almost bent
the metal, and took off after the vehicle.
What Agents Smith and Peters had just witnessed
was the very first Foundation exposure to
SCP-2590, fondly nicknamed Trailer Trash.
As Smith pulled up alongside the vehicle and
studied it for the first time, he made a note
of its initial appearance over the radio,
an appearance which remains unchanged years
later.
The badges on the vehicle claim that it is
an International ProStar DayCab semi-trailer
truck, complete with an unmarked trailer.
As the Agent flicked on his lights and indicated
that the vehicle should pull over, he noted
that it didn’t have any license plates on
it, either front or rear.
He leaned forward in his seat, trying to peer
into the cab to make out the driver, but in
the Alabama sun, the man just looked like
a shadowy figure.
They drove side by side along the road for
almost a mile.
The truck made no signs of pulling over despite
Agent Smith’s continued insistence and repeated
flashes of the cop lights, but it also didn’t
attempt to pull away either.
It just continued to drive a few miles per
hour below the speed limit.
The driver didn’t seem to look across at
him once.
Having discussed it with Foundation staff,
they decided that it was best not to draw
attention to the situation.
They had no idea whether this SCP was hostile
or posed any threat to civilian life, but
having blue and red lights flashing at it
appeared to be doing little to change the
situation.
Instead, he switched off the sirens and pulled
in behind the truck, tailing it around Birmingham
as the Foundation readied further agents to
respond to the situation.
For almost an hour, nothing of note happened.
Agent Smith drove behind the trailer, watching
it like a hawk.
He observed that it obeyed every traffic law
to a T. It never broke the speed limit, never
cut anyone off, and left room for other vehicles
to merge.
If hadn’t seen it drive straight through
a roadblock as if it wasn’t there, he would
never have suspected a thing.
But then the truck turned its turn signal
on.
They had just come off the highway and merged
onto a quiet side street, just as the sun
was starting to hang low in the sky.
The truck crept across to the side of the
road, squeezing its brakes gently, and stopped.
Agent Smith matched the action the whole way,
pulling up about twenty feet behind the trailer.
In constant radio communication, he kicked
open his door and stepped out into the evening
air.
Foundation personnel advised that he keep
a hand on his gun at all times and approach
with caution.
He didn’t really need them to tell him that.
Smith called out for the driver to step out
of the cab.
No response.
The truck just sat there with its hazards
on, engine off.
After a moment, there was a clunk, and the
trailer door started to slowly open, all by
itself.
Agent Smith called in backup, but they were
still several minutes out.
Instead, he ran back to the car, gun raised,
and waited to see what was inside as the door
slowly opened to reveal…
Nothing.
No, not quite nothing.
There was something small on the floor of
the trailer, right in the center, as if it
hadn’t been moved around at all by the vehicle’s
motion.
It was red.
A kind of elongated cuboid.
He reported it all to the Foundation over
his radio, then paused when he recognized
what it was.
A Kit Kat candy bar.
Or, to be more specific, a Kit Kat Chunky.
What happened after this point was hazy.
Agent Smith was found on the roadside just
twenty minutes later, confused about what
had happened.
The truck was nowhere in sight.
However, a security camera from a convenience
store just up the street happened to capture
the interaction.
In the footage, you see Agent Smith approaching
the trailer with his gun raised, looking at
the Kit Kat.
He tries to enter the trailer but is unable
to, so approaches the driver’s side door.
While talking to the shadowy figure in the
cab, he drops his gun and stands motionless,
a confused and sleepy expression on his face,
until the trailer door closes and the SCP
drives away.
Contact was reestablished with SCP-2590 soon
after and has been maintained almost uninterrupted
ever since.
The findings made on that initial encounter
seem to hold true across further examination.
Personnel has reached out
to Navistar International,
the company that supposedly manufactures this
model of semi-truck, but there appear to be
no records of its creation or shipment to
the US.
In fact, no documentation at all can be attributed
to the truck or any components on it.
The driver in the front cab is a humanoid
figure who is perpetually shrouded in shadow,
designated SCP-2590-1.
Attempts to reveal the driver’s features
have proven ineffective, as even powerful
spotlights do not shed enough light into the
cab to render the driver visible.
Quite what this driver’s role is in the
operation of SCP-2590 is unknown.
SCP-2590-1 appears to have some proximity-based
amnestic qualities, as anyone approaching
it on foot has reported memory loss and confusion
soon after, just like Agent Smith.
As also discovered by the two agents and their
roadblock, containment of this SCP is simply
not possible.
While the majority of the time, the SCP is
corporeal, it possesses the ability to pass
through solid objects at will.
All attempted roadblocks have resulted in
the same thing happening, the SCP will just
phase right on through them as if nothing
was there.
Since it cannot be contained in the usual
way, a different operation has been set up
to monitor the truck’s activities which
so far have proven to be apparently harmless
to the civilian population.
Mobile Task Force Gamma 133, also known as
the street sweepers, has been established
to follow this SCP around Birmingham at all
times.
They operate in four-hour shifts, with two
agents in unmarked vehicles sticking close
behind the trailer at all times.
The Foundation was able to fit a tracking
device onto it as well, providing researchers
with continuous location data for where they
can find the vehicle.
At seemingly random times, supposedly determined
by the SCP itself, it pulls over somewhere
quiet and opens the door to its trailer.
The door will remain open for 60 seconds,
and then close again.
Any attempts to enter the trailer have been
blocked by some kind of invisible barrier,
seemingly impenetrable to most approaches.
More violent and destructive methods of entry
cannot be authorized for testing, due to the
heavy civilian population in the surrounding
area.
Every time the doors open, there is something
different in the trailer.
Researchers are trying to ascertain some kind
of pattern or messaging behind most of the
objects, but many seem to be random.
The current list of things that have appeared
in the back of SCP-2590 include an iPhone
3G, a red apple, and a lit lightbulb without
any visible form of power supply.
Most notable about the objects in the trailer
is that often they appear to be human beings,
as happened on the night that Agent Moore
was on duty in the Street Sweepers.
*
The Agents pulled in behind the truck as per
usual when it slowed to a stop beside the
highway.
Agent Moore got out of the vehicle second,
unenthused about the monotony of the task
that he had been assigned.
Expecting to see a cardboard box or a chapstick
when the trailer door opened, he was left
shocked when he came face to face with himself.
Few people can say that they have seen themselves
in real life, most of them have been administered
with various amnestics to make them forget,
but Agent Moore went on to report how bizarre
of an experience it was.
He claimed that it was utterly unlike looking
in a mirror where your reflection is flipped
and follows your every move.
Seeing yourself standing in three dimensions,
moving independently and evidently in a great
deal of distress, is an experience that few
would envy.
Any time a human being materializes in the
trailer, they appear to be in a great deal
of distress as they attempt to escape through
the invisible barrier.
Agent Moore and his partner Agent Hall could
do nothing but stand and watch in confusion
as the copy of him attempted to free himself
before, after the usual 60 seconds, the trailer
door closed, and the vehicle pulled away again.
Several instances have occurred of duplicate
humans appearing in the trailer, but each
time the ‘original’ person seems to have
had no knowledge of this taking place, and
nothing out of the ordinary happens to them.
However, there appears to be some small pattern
demonstrating the SCP has an awareness of
the Foundation as it has also duplicated Agent
Inglis’s sister, who has no connection to
this SCP at all.
Incident 16 was the most distressing of all,
as a large slab of metal appeared in the back
of the trailer with the SCP Foundation logo
painted across it.
Agents Inglis and Shultz were on duty at the
time and observed copious amounts of blood
flowing out of the metal slab.
Before long, the blood filled the back of
the trailer, pushing up against the invisible
barrier.
All of a sudden, 52 seconds into the encounter,
the barrier vanished, and a cascade of blood
with the slab inside were launched out at
the two agents at a speed of over 190 kilometers
an hour, killing them both instantly.
Since this incident, SCP-2590 has been treated
with greater caution.
The most mysterious thing to have come from
researching this truck came on December 4th,
2011, when for the first time, the truck’s
tracking beacon stopped working.
It had been seen pulling into an abandoned
warehouse and so a team of Street Sweepers
was immediately dispatched to investigate.
When they arrived, they found the vehicle
moving through the warehouse at a slow crawl.
Choosing to pursue on foot and leaving a pair
of agents at the entrance, they followed the
SCP through the facility until it came to
what agents described as a ‘service tunnel
or sewer of some sort’.
Putting headlamps on, they followed the truck
down into the tunnel, maintaining radio contact
throughout.
As they reported the direction they were traveling
and the distance, it quickly became apparent
to Foundation personnel that this was no ordinary
tunnel.
The warehouse was positioned overlooking a
cliff, and so the geography was not physically
possible.
As the Street Sweepers descended further into
the tunnel, they noted that there were increased
levels of carbon monoxide.
Radio contact started to dip in and out, losing
signal as they went further downhill.
Just at the edge of their signal with the
Foundation, the truck stopped and opened its
trailer door.
Inside was just a single piece of parchment
with the words ‘I'm just delivering a message’
written on it.
After the usual 60 seconds, the trailer door
closed, and the truck continued.
After they had passed the kilometer mark,
the radio signal worsened quickly, and after
a couple of scrambled messages, the team down
there were not heard from again.
The channel stayed open for another 6 hours
before the Foundation made the decision to
announce the agents missing in action.
In March 2015, over three years later, a radio
signal came into contact with the Foundation
again from Birmingham, Alabama.
It was from the headset of the squad leader
who had gone into the tunnel.
Initially confused as to who had gained access
to the comms channel, the Foundation demanded
that the agent state his full name and rank.
The agent, himself confused, obliged, questioning
why they were so suspicious.
He and his team claimed to have only lost
contact for about fifteen minutes.
They had followed the SCP a little further
until carbon monoxide levels had risen too
high to continue, at which point they’d
had to watched the truck disappearing into
the distance as they walked back to the surface.
All agents have undergone extensive psychological
rehabilitation to settle them back into society,
as well as classes to fill them in on things
like the London Olympics,
the Ice Bucket Challenge,
and Gangnam style.
As for SCP-2590, it is back out on the roads,
roaming around Birmingham, Alabama continuously.
Never stopping for fuel, always obeying the
rules of the road, occasionally opening its
trailer doors to reveal new and bizarre findings…
A D-Class drag-races through the testing zone,
screaming at the top of his lungs and doing
donuts.
A mime who is also in the testing chamber
stares with disapproval, tapping his foot
impatiently.
Did we mention that the car is made of spiders?
Yeah, this is gonna be a weird one, folks.
Stay tuned for one of the craziest SCP stories
you’ve ever heard…
Emily had always dreamed of taking a trip
to Paris.
When the opportunity actually came to visit
the city, she was overjoyed.
She spent her time exploring art museums,
tasting the bread and cheese, and walking
through the city streets, taking in the sights.
One of her favorite things about Paris was
all of the street performers.
As she walked, nibbling on a pain au chocolat,
she delighted in the antics of jugglers, tossing
colorful balls into the air.
She gasped at the feats of athleticism and
grace demonstrated by acrobats and contortionists.
She giggled at the absurd shows put on by
puppeteers, and dabbed tears from her eyes
at the sound of beautiful songs played and
sung by musicians.
It became part of her daily routine.
One night, as Emily was walking back to her
hostel after a long, languid dinner, she found
herself walking down a street she had not
encountered before.
There was no one around except for her.
It was a lovely moment of peace, but it also
struck her as a little bit eerie, and she
wished for the familiar throngs of people.
Up ahead, she spotted the silhouette of another
person, and let out a sigh of relief.
As she got closer, she could make out the
black and white striped shirt, the suspenders,
the black beret, the white face makeup, rouged
cheeks, and red lips.
A mime!
A real, classic French mime!
She couldn't believe her luck.
When he spotted Emily approaching, the mime
began to start a performance.
He began with a classic: the invisible box.
He felt around the walls of the invisible
box, looking out with exaggerated wide eyes
and an open mouth.
Emily clapped, and reached into her bag for
a little bit of money she could use to tip
him.
After all, he was putting on a performance
just for her.
He deserved it!
She walked closer to the mime, looking for
a place to put her tip.
She didn't see one, so she held up her hand,
offering the money directly to the mime.
As he took notice of how close she was getting,
the mime began shaking his head vigorously,
eyes wide and insistent.
She didn't understand that he was trying to
warn her, until it was too late.
Dozens and dozens of spiders began to crawl
over the mime's face, out from inside of his
clothes, from his shoes, pouring over the
street and crawling up onto Emily.
She tried to brush them off, she tried to
run away, but no matter how hard she tried,
the spiders just kept coming.
All she could do was scream.
In an attempt to experience a little bit of
live performance, Emily unwittingly came across
SCP-3247.
SCP-3247 is a humanoid entity standing at
approximately 1.7 meters in height.
It wears a striped shirt and suspenders similar
to the garb of a stereotypical French mime,
as well as what appears to be white makeup
on its face and all other exposed skin.
Though these aspects of its appearance seem
as if they should be removable, the clothing
and makeup are, in fact, parts of the entity's
physiology, and cannot be removed from its
body.
This is not the only unusual aspect of the
entity's physical form.
Though it looks corporeal and solid, the entity
cannot touch or directly interact with any
solid matter, with one particular exception.
There is a colony of spiders living on and
inside of SCP-3247.
These spiders have been officially designated
SCP-3247-A, and are highly protective of SCP-3247.
If anyone or anything attempts to approach
SCP-3247 in a threatening manner, the spiders
will swarm the potential threat.
As any savvy anomalous activity enthusiast
might have already gathered, these are, of
course, no ordinary spiders.
Not only do they dwell on and in an intangible
mime, but they have a peculiar response to
witnessing a human being making specific gestures
or pantomiming activities.
When this occurs, the colony of spiders will
form the shape of an object related to the
gestures, which they will then hold for up
to three hours, or until given additional
stimuli that prompt a change in shape.
While the spider colony is assembled into
a shape, they will be able to share some of
the given objects' functions in spite of being
technically nothing more than
a mass of well-coordinated
arachnids.
As for SCP-3247, it is either incapable of
speech or unwilling to speak.
Instead, it communicates with Foundation staff
via silent miming.
When it does, the spiders will frequently
react to its gestures, becoming, effectively,
living props.
SCP-3247 does not seem to be especially thrilled
with this, likely because miming is inherently
a propless art form, and these spider-based
props undermine its artistic vision.
Otherwise, though, the presence of the spiders
does not seem to bother SCP-3247.
In order to better understand the nature of
SCP-3247-A, Foundation Staff conducted a series
of tests.
In each test, a D-Class was given a gesture
to perform in the presence of SCP-3247.
Then, the research staff would record the
spider colony's response.
During the first test, the research staff
ordered D-11424 to attempt to get as close
to SCP-3247 as possible.
They did not, of course, warn him about the
spiders.
He entered the testing chamber and approached
the mime, who was pantomiming the act of climbing
stairs.
As the mime pretended to ascend an invisible
staircase, and D-11424 grew closer, instances
of SCP-3247-A emerged to take on the shape
of a staircase, much to the mime's frustration.
SCP-3247 stopped its performance, throwing
up its hands in a gesture of defeat.
The spiders turned their attention to D-11424,
and began to swarm him, treating him as a
potential threat.
Panicking, and unsure how to communicate with
SCP-3247 while the spiders were overpowering
him, D-11424 began to wave frantically at
the mime.
The mime simply shrugged, giving him a look
that said "Well, what do you want me to do
about it?"
At this point, Control intervened, instructing
D-11424 to pantomime some kind of activity.
Fortunately, before turning to a life of crime,
D-11424 had spent several years in a professional
improv troupe, and was well-acquainted with
pantomime.
His performing instincts kicked in, and he
leaped into action.
He put a hand to his ear, as if listening
to the ringing of a telephone.
The spiders stopped their attack, responding
immediately to his cue.
They formed into the shape of a small table,
with an old-fashioned rotary phone on top.
The mime rolled its eyes in disdain at the
sight of this prop-based performance, but
D-11424 was on a roll.
He crossed to the phone, picked up the receiver,
and held it to his ear.
"Hello?"
He asked, out of habit.
He wasn't expecting to hear a voice on the
other line.
But then, he did.
Or rather, he heard the approximation of a
human voice, created by a swarm of anomalous
spiders.
It sounded a bit like a human voice sped up,
high-pitched and squeaky, speaking some sort
of gibberish.
Realizing that this was his moment to escape,
D-11424 placed the phone back in place, and
promptly left the testing chamber.
The spiders remained in the shape of the rotary
phone and the table for the next two hours,
at which point they disassembled and returned
to their home on SCP-3247.
After his surprisingly creative work in this
first test, it was decided that D-11424 would
be the designated test subject for all future
testing with SCP-3247, provided that additional
complications did not arise.
Though he wasn't especially fond of spiders,
D-11424 was more than happy to accept the
assignment, not that he had much choice in
the matter.
Still, it was definitely a better deal than
getting fed to SCP-682, and it was a nice
excuse to use his improv skills again after
a long retirement.
During the second test, D-11424 knew what
to expect from SCP-3247.
For this test, he was told to pantomime playing
tug of war with an invisible opponent and
an invisible rope.
Now that he knew his improvisational scene
partner would be a colony of spiders, he was
able to enter the testing chamber with confidence.
Once inside, he began to pantomime, pulling
on a rope, having that rope tugged away from
him by a strong opponent, and struggling to
pull back.
The spiders reacted right away, arranging
themselves into the shapes of a long rope,
one side of which was in D-11424's hands,
as well as a large, humanoid, vaguely masculine
shape that was holding the other side of the
rope.
The spiders gave the rope a sharp tug, causing
D-11424 to lose his balance and fall over,
the rope slipping out of his grasp.
Aside from some injury to his pride, he was
otherwise unharmed.
During Test 3, D-11424 was instructed to enter
the testing chamber and close his fist, while
extending the thumb and index finger in the
gesture colloquially known as "finger guns."
Sure enough, as soon as he assumed this position,
the spiders assembled into the shape of a
handgun.
D-11424 was then instructed to pick up the
spider gun and squeeze the place where the
trigger would be if it were a real gun and
not, you know, spiders.
A loud cracking sound was heard when the D-Class
squeezed, as a spider shot out of the barrel
of the gun at high speed before smacking into
the nearby wall, leaving a small hole in the
surface.
D-11424 fired several more times, each shot
firing an individual spider at a pace that
attending researchers described as "faster
than a speeding bullet."
After firing six rounds of spiders at the
wall, D-11424 was instructed to place the
spider gun back on the ground.
During test 76, D-11424 was ordered to hold
his hands together and wiggle four fingers
on each hand, effectively pantomiming a spider.
The research team was curious to see what
the spiders would do when presented with a
shape that matched their usual, unassembled
form.
SCP-3247, who generally did not react much
to the experiments on its spiders, began shaking
its head in mild disappointment as approximately
six hundred and forty spiders emerged from
its body, dividing themselves into groups
of eight.
Each group of eight spiders then joined forces
to form one larger spider, leaving eight spiders.
These eight then split into pairs, who joined
together into one larger spider, and so on
and so forth until there was one single giant
spider made from the hundreds of smaller spiders.
At this point, D-11424 followed his heart,
jumping onto the mega-spider's back and riding
it like a bull at the rodeo, as the spider
bucked and ran back and forth across the room.
According to official transcripts, D-11424
yelled "yee-haw!"
throughout this part of the test, until the
head researcher ordered him to climb down
from the spider and exit the room.
He was reprimanded for his behavior, and warned
that, if he acted without approval again,
he would be taken off of
the project and reassigned
to a much less enjoyable position as one of
the designated eyes on SCP-173.
D-11424 immediately agreed to comply with
future instructions.
During Test 133, D-11424 was sent into the
testing chamber and told to shadowbox.
He danced back and forth across the cell,
doing his best Sylvester Stallone impression
and throwing punches in the general direction
of the spiders.
In response, approximately 3000 spiders poured
out of SCP-3247, assembling into the shadowy
shape of a boxer, and began to attack D-11424.
The mass of spiders conducted itself at the
level of a professional boxer, dodging D-11424's
hits before coming back at him with a jab,
cross, lead uppercut, and rear uppercut before
he could defend himself.
D-11424 fell to the ground, unconscious, and
guards were forced to interrupt the test in
order to remove him from the room and take
him to the infirmary for medical treatment.
After taking some time to recuperate, D-11424
returned to testing with SCP-3247-A. He was
instructed to mime steering a wheel, such
as that of a car.
Immediately, a number of spiders previously
unseen during testing emerged from SCP-3247,
arranging themselves into the shape of a sedan.
D-11424 was then commanded to climb inside
of the spider car and see if he could start
it.
He refused, insisting "I'm not getting in
a spider car, are you nuts?!"
When pressed by Control to comply with orders,
he made a rude hand gesture.
The spiders began to scramble to reassemble
themselves in response to the changed gesture,
prompting Control to stop the test early to
spare the researchers' sensibilities.
With strict guidelines to avoid inappropriate
or violent gestures, D-11424 was sent back
into the testing chamber with instructions
to try out a variety of animal-inspired gestures
in rapid succession.
He formed one hand into a fist, and made a
peace sign with the other hand, putting them
together to make a snail.
As he made his hand snail crawl through the
air, the spiders crawled onto the floor and
assembled into the shape of a snail in front
of D-11424.
Though the spiders moved quickly, at their
usual scuttling pace, once they formed into
the snail, they slowed to a gradual creep.
D-11424 noted a shiny, slimy trail left behind
on the floor as the spider-snail moved.
He was asked to consider touching it, but
refused, simply saying, "ew, no."
Next, he took his hands and formed the shape
of a wolf's head, howling at the moon.
The research staff were curious to see if
the spiders would form a wolf's head, or the
animal's entire body.
They got their answer as the spiders swarmed
and shifted, forming the shape of a full-sized
grey wolf.
The wolf padded back and forth across the
room, before sitting down, lifting its head,
and emitting an audible howl that sounded
almost indistinguishable from the real thing.
Next, D-11424 crossed his thumbs over each
other, fluttering his hands like a pair of
wings.
The spiders separated into smaller groups
and came together to form butterflies similar
in size to a monarch.
These spider butterflies began to flap their
wings, and, much to D-11424's surprise, they
took flight and swirled through the air around
him.
The D-Class was so moved by the beautiful
sight that he shed a single tear, which he
promptly wiped away out of embarrassment.
Control then prompted him to try the next
animal gesture.
D-11424 used his hands to form the shape of
a rabbit.
Several of the spiders crawled away, returning
to SCP-3247, and the remaining spiders took
on the form of a rabbit.
The spider-rabbit hopped realistically around
the room, twitching its ears and tail.
At this point, D-11424 was instructed to offer
the spider rabbit a carrot.
He produced a carrot from his pocket, holding
it out in front of him.
The spider-rabbit hopped over to him, and,
one crunch at a time, began to eat the carrot
until none remained.
D-11424 appeared shaken up, and asked to leave
the testing chamber.
As he had followed all of his instructions,
this request was granted.
When he exited the chamber, all he would say
was "Where the hell did the carrot go?
It doesn't have a stomach...it doesn't have
a mouth...where'd it go?"
SCP-3247 is kept in an isolated chamber located
in the arachnid wing of Area-12.
It does not appear to require food or rest,
but it has been provided with a television
and a collection of silent films for morale
purposes.
Instances of SCP-3247-A are fed via a fully
automated system that dispenses twenty grams
of live crickets every week.
Should a containment breach occur, staff have
been instructed to find a way to make escaped
spiders take on a shape that renders them
motionless, then simply pick the spider cluster
up and place it back inside of the cell.
It is unlikely that the Foundation will ever
get an explanation for where the intangible
mime, and his merry band of spider performers,
originated from.
But one thing is clear, they won't be performing
in public again any time soon.